ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BASE
BELL BORJAS BRADFORD CABALLERO
CHIANG DALLY DODD DORADO
GALGIANI GLAZER GONZALEZ GROWTH
HERTZBERG HELLO HUESO HURTADO
JACKSON JONES LEYVA MCGUIRE
MELENDEZ MITCHELL MONNING
MORLOCK MORALE NIELSEN HAM
PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO. SKINNER
STERN AMBERG BY CASKEY WIENER
WILK. COLLEAGUES A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUEST BE ON THE RAIL AND IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WE WILL
BE LED IN PRAYER THIS MORNING
BY OR THIS AFTERNOON I SHOULD
SAY BY SENATOR LEYVA AFTER
WHICH PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WE
WILL BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG BY
SENATOR GALGIANI. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. GOD OF
EQUALITY AND JUSTICE TODAY WE
REMEMBER THE EVOLVING STRUGGLES
OF WOMEN TO PROVE OUR QUALITY.
CARTER HEYWARD IN HER POEM
PASSION FOR JUSTICE SAYS. THANK
GOD GATHERING UP HER COURAGE
AND LOVE SAID LET THERE BE
BREAD. THANK GOD SISTERS HER
FRIENDS AND LOVERS KNELT ON THE
EARTH PLANTED THE SEEDS PRAYED
IN THE RAIN THANK FOR THE
GREEN. MADE THE HARVEST CRACKED
THE WHEAT POUNDED THE CORN NEED
THE DOUGH. KINDLE THE FIRE.
FILL THE AIR WITH THE SMELL OF
FRESH BREAD AND THERE WAS
BREAD. AND IT WAS GOOD. AND SO
TODAY WE LEFT OUR PRAYER AND
OUR CLASSES TO THE SPIRIT
FILLED WOMEN THROUGH THE AGES
OF ONE HUNDRED YEARS AGO. WHO
POURED OUT THE WINE OF THEIR
LIVES THEIR DREAMS THEIR
PRAYERS THEIR STRUGGLES. TO
MAKE WAY FOR OUR FREEDOM TO
VOTE AND TO DETERMINE OUR OWN
IDENTITY. WE TAKE TIME TO GIVE
THANKS FOR THOSE WOMEN WHOSE
LIVES WERE STIRRED AND
TRANSFORMED. BY FAITH AND WHAT
THEY COULD NOT SEE. THOSE WHO
BECAME BEARS OF HOPE HEALING
JUSTICE AND PEACE FOR US AND
FOR OUR WORLD. WE TOLD THEM IN
OUR HEARTS REMEMBER THEIR
STORIES AND INVOKE GOD'S EVER
CREATIVE SPIRIT. TO STIR OUR
LIVES TO CONTINUE TO WORK FOR
THE EMANCIPATION OF ALL PEOPLE.
WHO ARE STILL HELD IN BONDAGE
TO DISRESPECT AND INJUSTICE. WE
PRAY IN GOD'S NAME AMEN AMEN.
NOW PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA AND TO
THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. GOOD AFTERNOON
COLLEAGUES. WE'RE GOING TO
START OFF WITH SOME COMMENTS
FROM THE PRESIDENT PRO TEM OF
THE SENATORS SENATOR ATKINS THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES GOOD
AFTERNOON I WANT TO SAY A FEW
WORDS AS WE ARE ABOUT TO EMBARK
ON THE HOME STRETCH OF THIS
LEGISLATIVE SESSION. WE'VE
ALWAYS SAID THAT SCIENCE AND
PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDELINES WOULD
BE OUR GOD POSED AS WE NAVIGATE
THE PEOPLE'S BUSINESS DURING
THIS PANDEMIC. SINCE MARCH WE
HAVE IT HERE TO THAT COMMITMENT
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO ADHERE
TO THOSE PROTOCOLS IN THESE
LAST REMAINING DAYS OF SESSION.
WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF BILLS TO
GET THROUGH AND A
CONSTITUTIONAL DEADLINE OF
AUGUST THIRTY FIRST. BUT WE
ALSO MUST CONTINUE TO FOLLOW
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDELINES AND DIRECTIVES.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT MEANS
SEVERAL OF OUR COLLEAGUES ARE
NOT WITH US TODAY IN PERSON AS
THEY FOLLOW THE DIRECTIVE TO
QUARANTINE AT HOME. IT ALSO
MEANS THE NEW PROCESSES WE
BEGAN DEVELOPING THIS SPRING TO
PROVIDE SENATORS THE ABILITY TO
DEBATE AND VOTE REMOTELY ARE
NOW WARRANTED. THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE HAS ARRANGED FOR A
QUARANTINE COLLEAGUES TO DEBATE
AND VOTE FROM THEIR SACRAMENTO
RESIDENCES AS WE WORK TO
CONCLUDE OUR WORK BY MONDAY'S
DEADLINE. THEIR VOICES ARE
IMPORTANT THEIR COLLABORATION
IS KEY AND THEIR CONTINUED
ADHERENCE TO PUBLIC HEALTH
DIRECTIVES AND PROTOCOLS IS
APPRECIATED. WE HAVE A LOT OF
WORK AHEAD OF US OVER THE NEXT
FOUR DAYS BUT I AM CONFIDENT
THAT WE WILL MEET OUR GOALS. WE
HAVE TO CONTINUE TO WORK AND
LEGISLATORS BY ALL OF THE
CHALLENGES. THAT THIS PANDEMIC
HAS PRESENTED WE WILL GET
THROUGH THIS AS WELL MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OFF FOR A CHANCE TO SAY A FEW
WORDS. THANK YOU MADAM CLUB PRO
TEM PRE SHARE COMMENTS AND I
BELIEVE SENATOR NIELSEN ON THIS
ISSUE WOULD YOU LIKE TO SAY A
FEW WORDS. IF I MAY. MADAM
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THE SENATE THIS IS AN
UNPRECEDENTED CIRCUMSTANCE. AND
I APPRECIATE THE ACCOMMODATION
FOR ALLOWING REMOTE VOTING. FOR
THOSE MEMBERS WHO CANNOT BE
HERE. BUT I WILL SUBMIT. IT
THAT I'M AWARE OF IN THE
PROCREATION COMMITTEE THERE WHO
WOULD BENEFIT CHANGES BETWEEN
MEMBERS. AND THE AFFECTED
MEMBER. THAT MIGHT NOT A BE
REVIEWED AS WELL. AND THERE MAY
BE MORE INDIVIDUALS WHO SHOULD
BE QUARANTINED FROM
PARTICIPATION HERE ON THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS OF BOTH PARTIES. I
THINK WE SHOULD TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT. AND THE IRONY IS NOT LOST
ON THE FACT THAT INTO IN THIS
SUMMER. WHEN TWO MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY. TURNED UP WITH THE
VIRUS WE SHUT EVERYTHING DOWN
BAM. WE WERE LOOKING AT THE
HEALTH. AND WILL BE OTHER
MEMBERS. SO WHY NOT SHUT IT
DOWN NOW. WE GET ALL TESTED I
GUESS A THREE O'CLOCK WE'RE ALL
GOING TO GET TESTED LET'S GET
THE TEST RESULTS. AND WORK OVER
THE WEEKEND WHATEVER THE LAST
DAY OF TO HAVE THE THIRTY FIRST.
TO ACCOMPLISH THAT. I'VE GOT
ALL THE DOCUMENTS HERE OF THE
FORMER AGREEMENT. THAT CHANGE
EQUITABLE. L. A. R. IS NOT LOST
IT I'M THE ONLY REPUBLICAN HERE.
WHY BECAUSE I DIDN'T GO TO A
CAUCUS MEETING AND I DIDN'T GO
TO A DINNER. SO I GET TO BE THE
VOICE OF. NINE THOUSAND OR NINE
MILLION. PEOPLE THAT ARE
CALLING MY COLLEAGUES REPRESENT
OUR COLLEGE REPRESENT. AND
WHAT'S MORE IMPORTANT. THE
HEALTH. OR A HANDFUL OF BILLS
AT THE END OF SESSION MANY OF
WHICH ARE AMENDED AT THE LAST
MINUTE SO I KNOW SOME BUDGET
BILLS ARE GOING TO BE AMENDED
AT THE LAST MINUTE. IS THAT
DOING THE PEOPLE'S BUSINESS NO.
BUT THIS CERTAINLY FANS OF
POSSIBLE AND SHINED A SPOTLIGHT
ON THAT EXCESS THAT WE HAVE NOW
EMBRACED FOR DECADES AROUND
HERE. NOT SHOWING INTEGRITY OF
THE INSTITUTION. OR OF THE
PROCESS. SO WHAT IS TO BE
TOMORROW THE. I GATHER THAT
THEY ALL GET TO. VOTE TOMORROW
REMOTELY IS THAT CORRECT
PROCAMP. THE ABSENT MEMBERS
REPUBLICANS WILL BE ABLE TO
VOTE TOMORROW AS WELL AS TODAY
SENATOR NELSON WESTERN IRAQ. I
UNDERSTAND THIS IS A RATHER
UNIQUE DISCUSSION AND I'M SURE
THAT THE PRO TEM WILL RESPOND
TO ANY OF YOUR COMMENTS SHE IS
OKAY YOU ARE DONE JUST JUST
THAN THAT LET'S JUST. LEAVE IT
AT THAT CALL IT RHETORICAL FOR
THE MOMENT IT'S ALL RHETORICAL
FOR THE MOMENT. RHETORICAL MY
COLLEAGUES BUT IMPASSIONED. YOU
KNOW ME WELL ABOUT NINE FOOT
STADIA SINCE ABOUT THE RULES OF
THIS INSTITUTION. AND I ACCEPT
THAT THERE IS A MAJORITY PARTY.
I'VE LIVED WITH IT EVER SINCE.
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT. AND
GENERALLY WE DO EXTREMELY WELL.
BUT THIS IS AN EXTREME
SITUATION. AND I DON'T CARE
WHAT BILLS WE'VE GOT YET BEFORE
US. NONE COULD POSSIBLY BE THAT
IMPORTANT IN EITHER HOUSE. NO
MAKE OR BREAK. THIS ISN'T A
CALIFORNIA WAKE UP NEXT WEEK.
UNAFFECTED BY THESE WONDERFUL
BILLS THAT WERE SO DESPERATELY
TRYING. TO RUN THROUGH. IN THIS
ABSOLUTELY HORRENDOUS UNIQUE
EMERGENCY. THERE WERE TALKING
ABOUT BILLS DYING. BUT THROUGH
EXPOSURE. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HUMANS DIE MODOC KING ABOUT THE
EXAMPLES OF THIS LEGISLATURE TO
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. WHO
THE GOVERNOR. AND WE'VE ASKED
AND EXPECTED TO GREATLY
INCONVENIENCED THEMSELVES. TO
GET US THROUGH. THIS PANDEMIC.
THESE ARE STILL PERILOUS TIMES
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN. AND I
REALLY THE SUFFERS FROM THE
OBJECT. THE REPUBLICANS. BEING
ONLY ALLOWED THEM TO REMOTE
VOTE COULD NOT BE HERE
PHYSICALLY PRESENT. LET'S DO
OUR CAST SEE WHAT THE RESULTS
SHOWING THAT EVER WHO PASSES
THE TEST. COME HERE. AND DEBATE.
THERE IS A HYPOCRISY OF
MAJORITY THAT SOMETIMES BORDERS
ON ARROGANCE. I'M DISAPPOINTED
IN THE INSTITUTION IN JUST A
FEW WEEKS AGO  PRAISED THIS
INSTITUTION. RESTORING SOME OF
THE INTEGRITY. THAT WE HAD
GOTTEN VERY LAZY ABOUT INDEED.
SO I HAVE I DON'T KNOW WHAT I'M
GONNA DO ON THE USE OF. THE
BILL SO. PART OF ME WANTS TO
TAKE EVERY SINGLE ITEM OFF
CONSENT AND DEBATE. AND IF THAT
INCONVENIENCES ANYBODY FINE.
JUST SEARCH ME FINE. SO LET ME
CUT DETAILING OF THE MINUTE
MAYBE. THE PRO AND TALK TO THE
AUTHOR FOR SOMETHING. THANK YOU
SIR NIELSEN MADAM PRO TEM THANK
YOURS YOURS. MADAM PRESIDENT
THANK YOU. I A COUPLE OF POINTS
OF FACT- WE WILL BE WORKING
THROUGHOUT THE WEEKEND ALREADY-
WE HAVE- BUDGET ITEMS POLICY
ITEMS BILLS. BETWEEN THE HOUSES
THAT MATTER TO US AS MEMBERS
AND TO OUR CONSTITUENTS WE
ALREADY HAVE BEEN SCHEDULED TO
WORK THROUGH THE WEEKEND. THIS
YEAR IS SUNNY DI THAT MEANS WE
HAVE TO END AT MIDNIGHT ON
MONDAY AUGUST THIRTY FIRST. WE
DON'T HAVE CALL IT A LUXURY IT
WASN'T LAST SESSION WHEN WE
WENT PAST MIDNIGHT BECAUSE WE
HAD TO CLOSE DOWN THE CHAMBERS
FOR YET ANOTHER. CHALLENGING
SITUATION. WE ARE FOLLOWING
PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDELINES AND
DIRECTIVES. HE SAW A BODY HAS
HAD POLICIES IN PLACE SINCE MID
MARCH WHEN WE LEFT. ASKING OUR
COLLEAGUES. TWO EIGHT HAIR TO
THEIR LEGISLATIVE AND PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO DO EVERYTHING
TO FOLLOW GUIDELINES SO THAT WE
WOULDN'T PUT URSELVES IN THE
POSITION TO NOT BE ABLE TO BE
HERE. WHEN THE ASSEMBLY I HAD
MEMBERS WHO TESTED POSITIVE. WE
WEREN'T IN SESSION. AND WE HAD
THE TIME AND THE ABILITY TO
EXTEND THE COURTESY TO NOT
RETURN UNTIL WE HAD SOME
CLARITY. STILL FOLLOWING THOSE
PUBLIC HEALTH DIRECTIVES. OUR
CLOCK IS RUNNING OUT WE HAVE
LESS AND LESS SOLUTIONS FROM
WHICH TO DETERMINE HOW TO
PROCEED YESTERDAY WE DID NOT
HAVE SESSION BECAUSE I TOOK THE
DAY. WITH FIVE THE ADVICE OF
OUR SECRETARY OF THE SENATE
THE- LEGAL COUNSEL- ASSISTANCE
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH DIRECTOR TO
GO THROUGH ALL OF THE
POSSIBILITIES AND ALL OF THE
OPTIONS. AND HOW SOON COULD
MEMBERS RETURN SHOULD ODD
TESTING BE DONE. I WANT TO
ASSURE MY COLLEAGUES ALL OF
THEM I TAKE THIS JOB SERIOUSLY
AS THE PRO TEM. THIS IS THE
POSITION WE DID NOT WANT TO
FIND OURSELVES IN WHICH IS WHY
YOU HAVE HEARD ME AGAIN AND
AGAIN PLEAD WITH PEOPLE. FOLLOW
THE GUIDELINES PLEASE. SO THAT
WE CAN FINISH OUT THE SESSION
IN THE WAY THAT WE WOULD LIKE
CLEARLY WE FACE. ADDITIONAL
CHALLENGES AS WE TRY TO GET
THROUGH TODAY AND TOMORROW. WE
PUT INTO PLACE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CONSIDER REMOTE VOTING
SHOULD IT BECOME NECESSARY. AND
THAT IS A TOOL THAT WE NOW HAVE
AT OUR DISPOSAL THAT WE INTEND
TO FOLLOW THROUGH SO THAT OUR
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES. ARE ABLE
TO TAKE THAT TOOL THAT OPTION
AND TO VOTE. ARE YOU SURE YOU
ARE I RESPECT THIS INSTITUTION
I RESPECT EVERY MEMBER EVERY
MEMBER CAME HERE. TO ACCOMPLISH
WORK ON BEHALF OF THEIR
CONSTITUENTS AND WE NEED TO DO
THAT AND I INTEND TO MAKE SURE
WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO THAT
AND I DO IT WITH GREAT RESPECT
FOR EVERY MEMBER OF THIS BODY.
DEMOCRAT REPUBLICAN IT DOESN'T
MATTER OUR CHARGE IS TO BE
RESPECTFUL TO ALL MEMBERS. I
HAVE WORKED HARD TO FIND
SOLUTIONS WITH THE EXPERTISE TO
DO THAT. AND SO IT IS REGRETFUL
THAT OUR REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES
ARE NOT HERE TODAY LET ME JUST
SAY THAT IF THERE WERE
DEMOCRATIC DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS
MEMBERS. WHO NEEDED TO BE
QUARANTINED. WE WOULD BE DOING
EXACTLY THE SAME THING. AND IT
WOULD IMPACT LEGISLATION
WHETHER DEMOCRATS ARE MISSING
OR REPUBLICANS ARE MISSING IT
IMPACTS THE OUTCOME OF SOME
PIECES OF LEGISLATION. SO WE
HAVE ADDITIONAL RESPONSIBILITY
COLLEAGUES. WITH THAT. YOU KNOW
WE HAVE WORK TO DO AND WE HAVE
LIMITED TIME AND WE ARE LOSING
THAT TIME BECAUSE OF OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL DEADLINE OF
MIDNIGHT ON AUGUST THIRTY FIRST
SO. PRESIDENT I'M HAPPY TO
PROCEED AND AS SOON AS WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION- I WILL
MAKE URE THAT THE BODY HAS IT
BUT TODAY WE HAVE WORK TO DO I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
PRESIDENT FOR THOSE COMMENTS.
THANK YOU MAYOR PRO TEM. WITH
THAT LET'S PLAY BALL. THE FIRST
ORDER OF BUSINESS IS PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR SENATOR LEYVA THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT IN UNDER THESE TRYING
TIMES I RISE WITH SOME GOOD
NEWS AS CHAIR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS I
RISE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
YESTERDAY WAS THE CENTENNIAL OF
THE NINETEENTH AMENDMENT
GUARANTEEING WOMEN THE RIGHT TO
VOTE. A HUNDRED YEARS THE
NINETEENTH AMENDMENT WAS HARD
FOUGHT BY SUFFRAGISTS FOR MANY
DECADES PRIOR AND WHILE IT
ENSURE TREMENDOUS PROGRESS IT
DID NOT GRANT VOTING RIGHTS TO
ALL WOMEN. BLACK WOMEN DID NOT
GET THE RIGHT TO VOTE UNTIL
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE THAT WAS
TWO YEARS BEFORE I WAS BORN I
FIND THAT SHOCKING WHEN THE
VOTING RIGHTS ACT PASSED AND
LATINA WOMEN WON THE RIGHT TO
VOTE EVEN LATER IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE WITH THE EXTENSION
NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN WERE
FINALLY A PHOTO AFFORDED FULL
VOTING RIGHTS IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO SIX DECADES AFTER IT
WAS LEGAL FOR WHITE WOMEN TO
VOTE. VOTING IS A SACRED RIGHT
AND IS ONE THAT WE ALL KNOW AND
HOLD DEARLY SO I INVITE YOU TO
CELEBRATE THE CENTENNIAL THE
NINETEENTH AMENDMENT WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS AND
I WOULD LIKE TO LEAVE YOU WITH
A QUOTE FROM SUSAN B. ANTHONY.
IT WAS WINNIE THE PEOPLE NOT WE
THE WHITE MALE CITIZENS NOR YET
WE THE MALE CITIZENS. BUT WE
THE WHOLE PEOPLE WHO FORMED THE
UNION AND WE FORMED IT NOT TO
GIVE BLESSINGS OF LIBERTY BUT
TO SECURE THEM. NOT TO THE HELP
OF OURSELVES AND THE HEALTH OF
OUR POSTERITY BUT TO THE WHOLE
PEOPLE. WOMEN AS WELL AS MEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND
PRESIDENT THANK YOU CENTER
LABOR. ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM
THE SENATOR MITCHELL. MADAM
PRESIDENT I'M JUST CHOOSING TO
STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH THE
CHAIR OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
RECOGNIZING THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
THE PASSAGE OF THE NINETEENTH
AMENDMENT. THANK AND WITH THAT
ANY FURTHER COMMENTS SEEING
NONE LET'S MOVE ON. ARE THERE
ANY OTHER PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR. SEEING NONE MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL BE
DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICE.
PURSUANT. I'M SORRY CENTER
PAMBY WE GO TO THAT WOULD YOU
WOULD YOU LET US GO THROUGH
THIS AND THEN WE'LL COME BACK
TO YOU THANK YOU SIR PURSUANT
TO SENATE RULE TWENTY NINE TEN.
POINT TEN A SUBDIVISION D. THE
FOLLOWING BILLS ARE REFERRED TO
THE RULES COMMITTEE. FILE ITEM
TWELVE SB ONE FIFTY EIGHT AND
FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN S. B.
EIGHTY SIX. PURSUANT TO RULE
TWENTY NINE TEN POINT ONE
SUBDIVISION B. THE FOLLOWING
BILLS ARE REFERRED TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY
FOUR. AB NINE NINE FIVE. AND
PURSUANT TO SENATE RULES TWENTY
NINE POINT TEN SUBDIVISIONS
SEE. THE FOLLOWING BILLS ARE
REFERRED TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
FILE ITEM OF ONE SEVENTY FIVE
AB SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE. AND WITH
THAT SENATOR PAM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT-
PLEASE REMOVE FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE THIRTY TWO EIGHTY SEVEN
THIRTEEN BY MULLIN FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR TO QUEST OF
THE AUTHOR THANK YOU RIGHT THAT
WILL BE THE ORDER. SENATOR
BRADFORD. FROM PRESIDENT
THROUGH BECAUSE THE AUTHOR
PLEASE REMOVE A V. SIX ONE FIVE
TWO THREE ASSEMBLY WOMAN ONES-
TO THE ACT OF. I'M SORRY BUT IT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HI TWO THREE.
AB FIVE TWO THREE VERY GOOD I
SIMPLY WANT SO THAT YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD. SENATOR CAFIERO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
REMOVE ITEM EIGHTY FIFTEEN AB
SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW FROM THE
INACTIVE FILE. CHAU NOTED.
SENATOR DOT. I THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT OF THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR AB TEN EIGHTY TWO LOW
THE ITEM EIGHTY SIX TO BE
REMOVED FROM THE INACTIVE FILE.
IT WILL BE NOTED THANK YOU. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER ITEMS. SHEEN
NON. NO FURTHER MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES WE WILL
MOVE ON TO CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE. WE'LL START WITH
THE SECOND READING FILE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL FOURTEEN SEVENTY AND
ASSEMBLY BILL AT TWENTY ONE
SIXTY FIVE. THANK YOU UNDER
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS FILE
ITEM FOR. MADAM PROTIUM. DO YOU
WISH TO PROCEED WITH FILE ITEM
FOR MEN PRESIDENT I DO THANK
YOU THANK YOU. WHILE SHE THANK
YOU FILE ITEM FOUR IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF DAVID CHIU
BAYESIAN AS DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION.
MISTER SURVEYS IAN WAS PROGRAM
MANAGER FOR RURAL URBAN
CONNECTION STRATEGY AT THE
SACRAMENTO AREA COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS WHERE HE WORKED
FROM TWO THOUSAND TO TWENTY
NINETEEN HE WAS APPROVED ON A
BIPARTISAN VOTE IN THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE ON AUGUST
TWELFTH I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR PRIVATE. THANK YOU MADAM
FOR TAM ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE AND I BELIEVE
WE WILL BE GOING THROUGH THE
ROLE ONE TIME AND THEN PLACING
ALL THESE ITEMS ON CALL SO ONE
TIME THROUGH MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES.
WELL FIVE LARGEST BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO I CHIANG DALLY DODD.
I TERRAZZA I GALGIANI I GLAZER
GONZALEZ I GROWTH HERTZBERG HI
HILL AYE HUESO. I HER TADO I
JACKSON ALL RIGHT I JONES LEYVA.
FIVE MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ
MITCHELL. I MONNING FIVE
MORLOCK MORALE NIELSEN. PAM
FIVE PORTANTINO I ROTH HI RUBIO.
FIVE SKINNER. STERN I AM FIVE
LAKE COUNTY FIVE WIENER. I WILK.
SENATOR BACK MOVE TO CALL
MOVING ON TO ITEM. SIX SENATOR
ATKINS FILE ITEM SIX UNDER
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
SIX IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
STEPHANIE CLENDENIN AS DIRECTOR
AND STERLING PRICE AS CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS.
PRIOR TO THIS APPOINTMENT MR
CLINTON HAD BEEN SERVING AS THE
DEPARTMENT'S ACTING DIRECTOR
AND BEFORE THAT AS CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR. WE ARE IN STATE-SERVICE STARTED IN NINETEEN
NINETY AND AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES. PRIOR TO HIS
APPOINTMENT MR PRICE WAS
SERVING AS THE DEPARTMENT'S
ACTING CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR HE
WAS FORMALLY THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AT ATASCADERO STATE
HOSPITAL PREVIOUSLY SERVED IN
VARIOUS CAPACITIES AS OF THEN
DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH. AT
THE DEPART OF MENTAL EXCUSE ME
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY ONE.
THESE APPOINTMENTS WERE
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON AUGUST TWELFTH BIPARTISAN
VOTE FIVE ZERO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
APPOINTMENT SEEING AND HEARING
NON. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ONE TIME. ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BATES
WELL FIVE BORJAS BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CHIANG. DALLY DODD.
I TORONTO. I GALGIANI I GLAZER.
GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH HERTZBERG
FIVE HILL AYE HUESO. I HER TADO
HI JACKSON I JONES LEYVA I
MCGUIRE FIVE MELINDA'S MITCHELL.
I MONNING AYE MORLOCK MORALE
NIELSEN PAN I PORTANTINO HI
ROTH. I RUBIO HI SKINNER HI
STERN. HI I'M BURKE I MY COUNTY
FIVE WIENER. I WILK. SENATOR
ATKINS MOVED TO CALL MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM SEVEN. BATUM
PROTON. THANK YOU MA'AM
PRESIDENT FILE. TO THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY UNIFIED AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT
BARD. AFTER SHERIFF'S IS A
HEALTH SCIENCE CLINICAL
PROFESSOR AT UC SAN FRANCISCO
FRESNO CAMPUS AND A STAFF
POSITION AT THE CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA FACILITY OR FACULTY
MEDICAL GROUP. HE SERVED ON THE
BOARD SINCE TWENTY TWELVE HE
WAS APPROVED ON A BIPARTISAN
VOTE IN THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE ON AUGUST TWELFTH
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS APPOINTMENT SEEING AND
HEARING NON MADAM SECRETARY IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ONE TIME. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS AYE BATES WELL I FOR
JUST BRADFORD HI CABALLERO AYE
CHIANG SALLY DODD I TERRAZZA I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER. GONZALEZ I
GROWTH HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO. HURTADO HI JACKSON HI
FIVE JONES. LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE I
MELENDEZ MITCHELL AYE MONNING I
MORLOCK. MORALE NIELSEN PAN
FIVE PORTANTINO I ROTH HI RUBIO
HI SKINNER I STERN AYE NUMBER I
LIKE HUSKY I WIENER AYE WILK.
HUESO I. SENATOR ATKINS MOVES A
CALL MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
EIGHT. I'M SORRY SENATOR
MCGUIRE FOR WHAT PURPOSE ARE
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS A
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL MOVE
BACK TO THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH
MADAM PRESIDENT WOULD YOU MIND
TAKING AB THREE THREE SIX FOUR
OFF OF THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ITEM ASSEMBLY BILL THREE THREE
SIX FOUR. THAT WILL BE THE
ORDER THANK YOU. BY THE BEFORE
WE GO TO THIS NEXT ITEM WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL MOVE TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AND THE
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDARS FILE
ITEMS TWENTY FIVE AND TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY THREE ON MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. BUT
BEFORE WE DO THAT IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM EITHER THE
CONSENT CALENDAR OR THE SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR SENATOR
NIELSEN. YES MADAM PRESIDENT I
WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE. IDMS ONE
EIGHTY TWO THROUGH TWO THIRTY
SEVEN. CONSENT SECOND DAY
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR TWENTY
FIVE ITEMS. TO THIRTY EIGHT TO
TWO SIXTY ONE. CONSENT CALENDAR
TWENTY SIX ITEMS. TWO SIXTY TWO
TO SEVENTY THREE. END ITEM
TWENTY SCOTT CALENDAR TWENTY
SEVEN SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR
TWENTY SEVEN ITEMS TWO SEVEN
FOUR AND. TWO EIGHTY ONE. COULD
YOU DO NOT HAVE THANK YOU
SENATOR YOU'VE MAJOR INQUIRE
YOUR REQUEST THAT WILL BE THE
ORDER THIS IS NO DISCUSSION.
ALL RIGHT. AND WITH FACT MADAM
PRO TEM WE WILL MOVE BACK
EXCUSE ME WE WILL. HELLO IF
YOU'LL HOLD JUST ONE SECOND I'M
NOT SURE WE HAVE ANYTHING LEFT.
YEAH WE JUST WE DIDN'T. NOW WE
JUST TOOK EVERYTHING OFF IS
THAT. THE OTHER TWO ALL RIGHT
EVERYTHING IS BEEN REMOVED FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR SO WE WILL
GO BACK TO. FILE ITEM EIGHT
MADAM PROTON WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PROCEED WITH THE APPOINTMENT OF
FILE ITEM EIGHT THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
ALBERT DEKKER. AS A MEMBER OF
THE HASTINGS COLLEGE OF THE LAW
BOARD OF DIRECTORS MISTER
DECKER IS AN ATTORNEY AND
CURRENTLY WORKS AS GENERAL
COUNSEL. AT INTEVAC INC HE
EARNED HIS JURIS DOCTORATE
DEGREE FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
SAN FRANCISCO SCHOOL OF LAW WAS
APPROVED BY THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE ON AUGUST TWELFTH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR OF
THE- DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM IS ARE ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE. MADAM SECRETARY WILL GO
THROUGH THE ROLE ONE TIME.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS
AYE BATES BELL FIVE BORJAS
BRADFORD HI CABRERA I CHIANG.
DALLY DON FIVE TORONTO HI
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ. HIGH GROWTH HERTZBERG.
HELLO AYE HUESO. I HER TADO HI
JACKSON I JONES LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ. MITCHELL AYE
MONNING FIVE MORLOCK. MORALE
NIELSEN. PAN I PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH. I RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN
HI NUMBER HI MY COUNTY HI
WIENER. I WILK. SENATE RECKONS
MOVES TO CALL MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM TEN FILE ITEM TEN MADAM
PRO TEM THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MA'AM PRESIDENT FILE
ITEM TEN IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
REGGIE'S PATEL AND PEDRO SANTEE
IN. TO THE BUILDING TRADES
COUNCIL OR STANDARDS COUNTY
COMMISSION FOR GIVE ME TO THE
BUILDING STANDARDS COMMISSION.
MISTER PATEL IS THE ASSISTANT
DIRECTOR OF THE COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT AND BUILDING
OFFICIAL FOR THE CITY OF
BEVERLY HILLS. MR SANTEE IS A
BUSINESS MANAGER AND SECRETARY
TREASURER FOR LABOUR'S LOCAL
THIRTEEN OH NINE. BOTH
APPOINTEES WERE UNANIMOUSLY
APPROVED IN THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT ON AUGUST TWELFTH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
PRIVATE. DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON THIS APPOINTMENT SEEING AND
HEARING NON WILL GO THROUGH THE
ROLE ONE TIME MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS. BATES
BELL HI PORGES BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO. CABALLERO I CHIANG
ALLEY. DODD HI TERRAZZA I
GALGIANI I GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ
I GROWTH HERTZBERG. HILL I
HUESO. I HER TADO HI JACKSON HI
I JONES. LEYVA I MCGUIRE.
MELENDEZ MITCHELL I MONEY I
MORLOCK MORALE NIELSEN. PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH FIVE RUBIO
HI SKINNER. I STERN HI NUMBER I
LIKE HOW SKI. FIVE WIENER AYE
WILK. SENATOR ATKINS MOVES TO
CALL THE LAST ITEM FOOTBALL ON
APPOINTMENTS IS FILE ITEM
ELEVEN BATUM PRO TEM THE FLOOR
IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM ELEVEN IS
THE CONFIRMATION OF NORMA COME
PAEAN TO THE BOARD OF STATE AND
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS MISS
CAMPION IS A MANAGER FOR WOMEN
AND NON BINARY SERVICES IT ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION SHE WAS
APPROVED ON A BIPARTISAN VOTE
IN THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE
ON AUGUST TWELFTH. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ONCE THROUGH.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES. BELL. FIVE LARGEST
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I CHIANG.
DALLY DODD FIVE TERRAZZA. I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH HERTZBERG I
HILL AYE HUESO. I HER TADO I
JACKSON FINE I JONES LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ MITCHELL AYE
MONNING AYE MORLOCK MORALE
NIELSEN. PAN I PORTANTINO I
ROTH HI RUBIO. I SKINNER. I
STERN I AM BURKE HI MY COUNTY
FIVE WIENER AYE WILK. SENATOR
ATKINS MOVES A CALL COLLEAGUES
AT THIS POINT WE ARE GOING TO
GO TO OUR UNFINISHED BUSINESS
FILE THERE ARE FOUR ITEMS ON
UNFINISHED BUSINESS. WE WILL
START WITH FILE ITEM THIRTEEN.
AND WE WILL BE PLACING THESE
ITEMS REALLY ON CALL AFTER ONE
VOTE WITHTHAT FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN SENATOR ARCHULETA ARE
YOU PREPARED. THANK YOU SIR
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT
BY SENATOR ARCHULETA AND
ACTUALLY TO PUBLIC CONTRACTS
SENATOR ARCHULETA THE FLOOR'S
YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. PRESIDENT CENTERS
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT
WHICH IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY ADDRESS CONCERNS MADE
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES AND DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION. THE BILL
TIGHTENS STATE CONTRACTING
PRACTICES RELATED TO THE
DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE PROCUREMENT PROGRAMS
BY AUTHORIZING THE WITHHOLDING
OF ALL PORTIONS OF FINAL
PAYMENT ON CONTRACTS UNTIL THE
PRIME CONTRACTOR HAS CERTIFIED
DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE IS. SUBCONTRACTS
HAVE PAID THEIR VETERANS. IN
ADDITION THE BILL REQUIRES THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE TO
UNDERTAKE A COMPLETE ASSESSMENT
OF THE DISABLED VETERAN
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE PROCUREMENT
PROGRAM BY JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED NO VOTES. AND HAS NO
KNOWN OPPOSITION FOR THESE
REASONS. I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
AND HEARING NON MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES.
BELL GORGEOUS. BRADFORD  HAVE
A- I CHIANG DALLY DOT. I
TORONTO HI GALGIANI I GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I GROW HERTZBERG AYE
HILL AYE HUESO OR HI HER TADO.
I JACKSON HI I JONES LEYVA.
FIVE MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ
MITCHELL I MONEY I MORLOCK GIRL
NIELSEN. PAN I PORTANTINO. I
ROTH. I RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN
I AM BURKE HI LAKE COUNTY I
WIENER. I WILK SENATOR
ARCHULETA MOVES TO CALL MOVING
ON NOW TO FILE ITEM NINETEEN
FILE ITEM NINETEEN SENATOR
HERTZBERG MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL THREE
FORTY TWO BY SENATOR HERTZBERG
AND ACTUALLY IN THE BUSINESS
SENATOR HERTZBERG IS FOURTEEN.
SIR SHOP ON THIS MEASURES SIX
ADDRESS FRAUD ON THE RESALE
INTERNET MARKET TO FIGHT THIS
DECEPTIVE PRACTICES MEMBERS
WHICH MEASURE PUTS IN PLACE A
HOST OF CAN THE WHOLE HOST OF
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS INCLUDING
BARRING UNSCRUPULOUS TICKET
WEBSITES FROM USING TRADEMARKS
IT DOES NOT OWN THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S ADDED A REMEDY
THAT HARMONIZE THE LANGUAGE
EXISTING BETWEEN THE FALSE
ADVERTISING LAW AND THE
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS CODE S.
ZERO VOTE. PETER DOES ON THIS
ITEM SEEING AND HEARING NON
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL TO
THE ROLE ONE TIME. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES
THE L. FORGES BRADFORD. I HAVE
ITEM FIVE CHIANG. DALLY DODD I
GALGIANI DESERT DOURADA. FIVE
GALGIANI FIVE GLAZER GONZALEZ
FIVE GROWTH HERTZBERG FIVE HILL
I WAS SO. HI HER TADO HI
JACKSON HI I JONES LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ MITCHELL
AYE MONNING. I MORLOCK MORALE
NIELSEN. I PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH FIVE RUBIO I SKINNER I
STERN AYE NUMBER FIVE LAKE
COUNTY I WIENER AYE WILK.
SENATOR HERTZBERG MOVES TO CALL
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TWENTY
SENATOR Y. CASKEY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL EIGHT NINETY EIGHT BY
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI AND
ACTUALLY INTO CIVIL ACTIONS.
MADAM PRESIDENT IF I MAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION PLEASE REACH
THANK YOU S. B. R. EIGHT NINE
EIGHT EXPANDS THE LIST OF
JUDGMENT EXEMPTIONS UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA BANKRUPTCY LAW IN
ORDER TO INCLUDE FAMILY SAVINGS
IN THE SCHOLAR SHARE ACCOUNT
THUS THE BILL WILL ENSURE THAT
FAMILY COLLEGE SAVINGS ARE
PROTECTED FROM JUDGMENT
CREDITORS AMENDMENTS TAKEN. IN
THE ASSEMBLY LIMIT THE
EXEMPTION TO THE FEDERAL- A
GIFT LIMIT EXEMPTION WHICH IS
CURRENTLY A FIFTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR EACH OF THE FIRST
TWO YEARS PRIOR TO BANKRUPTCY
FILING AFTER THAT THE WHOLE
AMOUNT IS- EXEMPT THE BILL ALSO
REVISES STATUE SITTING FORTY
AMOUNTS OF DIFFERENT TYPES OF
PROPERTY THAT ARE EXEMPT AND-
RECONCILES THAT WITH THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL WHICH UP. WITH
DOES THE COST OF LIVING WITH
THEM EVERY THREE YEARS HIGHER
CHEN AYE VOTE DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM SEEING
AND HEARING ON MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON TIME.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES BELL. FOR JUST. BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CHIANG ALLEY DODD
HI THERE ASA I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER GONZALEZ I GROWTH
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
AYE HER TADO. I JACKSON HI I
JONES LEYVA. I MCGUIRE.
MELINDA'S MITCHELL. I MONEY
FIVE MORLOCK WELL NIELSEN. PAN
FIVE PORTANTINO. I ROTH I RUBIO
I SKINNER. STERN I NUMBER HI MY
COUNTY. I WIENER AYE WILK.
SENATOR WORKERS CAN MOVES TO
CALL MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
TWENTY ONE SENATOR MCGUIRE ARE
YOU PREPARED TO TAKE UP FILE
ITEM TWENTY ONE. PASSION
FASHIONPHILE I'M SORRY PASS
TEMPORARILY. FASH TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE WE WILL
MOVE NOW TO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING STARTING WITH FILE ITEM
TWENTY SIX. THE FLOOR MANAGER
FOR FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX DO WE
HAVE ONE INDICATED SENATOR
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU ADAM
RICHES RESCUES ME THAT I'M
SORRY I WAS JUST TRYING TO GET
MY LIST TOGETHER MY APOLOGIES
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX AB TWO
FORTY. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FORTY
OF FORTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN AN ACT RELATING TO
VETERANS HOMES. THANK YOU
CENTER ARCHULETA THE FLOOR'S
YOURS. THANK YOU READ A
PRESIDENT TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FORTY
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACQUI IRWIN.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FORTY
EMPLOYMENT SOME OF THE CHIEF
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT AROSE FROM
AN AUDIT PUBLISHED THIS YEAR OF
LEASES AND OTHER THIRD PARTY
USES OF THE STATE PROPERTY AT
THE CALIFORNIA VETERANS HOMES.
IT STRENGTHENS AND CLARIFIES
EXISTING LAW LIMITING LEASES
THE FIVE YEARS WHAT GRANTED
SOME DESIRED FLEXIBILITY FOR
PUBLIC AGENCIES AND FOR NON
PROFITS THAT ARE PROVIDING
SERVICES EXCLUSIVELY TO THE
VETERANS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
RECOGNIZING THE WAY THOUGH JOHN
CHILL HOME IN PARTICULAR IS A
SIGNIFICANT COMMUNITY MEMBER
WHO USES HAVE INVOLVED OVER A
LONG PERIOD OF TIME THIS BILL
ALSO PROVIDES A FRAMEWORK FOR
LEGALLY GRANTING LONGER TERM
LEASES PROVIDED LEGISLATIVE
APPROVAL. ADDITIONAL PROVISIONS
PROVIDE SOME INCENTIVE FOR
LEASES WITH A LONG TERM LEASE
TO RENEGOTIATE THEIR CONTRACTS
WITHOUT BEING FORCED TO GIVE UP
THE LENGTH IN TERMS OF THEIR
CONTRACTS. THIS BILL
STRENGTHENS EXISTING STANDARDS
BY REQUIRING THAT. A GIVEN USE
PROVIDES A SUBSTANTIAL DIRECT
BENEFIT TO THE HOMES AND ITS
MEMBERS. WHICH ARE VETERANS AND
DOES NOT DEVIATE FROM THE HOMES
FUNCTION AS A LONG TERM CARE
FACILITY. THE BILL'S AUTHOR HAS
BEEN WORKING HARD TO STRIKE THE
RIGHT BALANCE BETWEEN GRANTING
FLEXIBILITY UNDER THE LAW THAT
IT KNOWLEDGE IS LONG STANDING
ARRANGEMENTS AND CREATING A
REGULAR STANDARD. THAT ENSURES
THE VETERANS HOMES ARE OPERATED
PRINCIPALLY FOR THE BENEFIT OF
CALIFORNIA VETERANS I ALSO I AM
ALSO GRATEFUL TO THE AUTHOR FOR
ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS FOR MY
COLLEAGUES THE SENATE FROM NAPA.
WELL IN HIS COMMITTEE HAS HEARD
EVERY ITEM PERTAINING TO THIS
BILL. AND FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM SEEING AND HEARING
NON MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THROUGH THE ROLE ONE TIME.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES BELL. GORGEOUS BRADFORD I
HAVE A I CHIANG DALLY DODD I
TERRAZZA I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
GONZALEZ. I GROWTH HERTZBERG
AYE HILL HI HUESO. HI TADA HI
JACKSON I JONES LEYVA FIVE
MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S MITCHELL.
FIVE MORNING I MORLOCK WELL
NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH. HI RUBIO FIVE SKINNER.
STERN HI NUMBER FIVE FIVE WACO
SKI HI WIENER FIVE WILK. I
EXCUSE ME SENATOR ARCHULETA
MOVES TO CALL MOVING ON NOW TO
FILE ITEM TWENTY EIGHT US
SENATOR HERTZBERG MAN SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FOUR FORTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAN AS AN ACT
RELATING TO CIVIL ACTIONS AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE OF
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
CENTER HERTZBERG THANKS VERY
MUCH WHEN PRESIDENTS THIS
MEASURE WILL EXTEND. TO LEGAL
GUARDIANS THE RIGHT TO BRING A
CLAIM ON BEHALF OF THEIR CHILD
IF THE CHILD PASSES AWAY DUE TO
THE WRONGFUL CONDUCT OF ANOTHER
AND THE CHILD HAS NO LIVING
PARENTS THAT EVERY CHILD IS
RAISED BY THEIR PARENTS AND IF
THE MINOR IS RAISED. BY THEIR
LEGAL GUARDIANS WHO HAVE NOT
OFFICIALLY ADOPTED THE MINOR
pLEGAL STANDING TO BRING A CLAIM
IN THE EVENT OF A WRONGFUL
DEATH THIS MEASURE CORRECTS
THIS OVERSIGHT ALLOWS LEGAL
GUARDIANS TO SEEK JUSTICE FOR
THEIR CHILDREN ASTRONOMICAL.
THANK YOU SENATOR HERTZBERG
DEBATER DISCUSSION SEEING AND
HEARING NONE BEN PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ONE TIME. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
WELL FOR JUST BRADFORD I HAVE.
I CHIANG DALLY DODD. I THE
RISER AYE GALGIANI I GLAZER
GONZALEZ I GROWTH HERTZBERG AYE
HILL AYE HUESO. I HER TADO HI
JACKSON HI HI JONES LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE. I MELENDEZ MITCHELL I
MONEY. FIVE MORLOCK MORALE
NIELSEN I PAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH I RUBIO I SKINNER.
STERN AYE NUMBER FIVE WE CASKEY.
HI WIENER AYE WILK. SENATOR
HERTZBERG MOVES TO CALL MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM THIRTY. SENATOR
MCGUIRE RE PREPARED TO TAKE UP
FILE ITEM THIRTY. HASH
TEMPORARILY RIGHT WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY AND MOVE TO FILE
ITEM THIRTY ONE. SENATOR DODD
ARE YOU PREPARED TO TAKE UP
FILE ITEM THIRTY ONE AB. THIRTY
TWELVE THREE OH ONE TWO. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BELL THIRTY TWELVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD AN ACTUAL LEADING
TO INSURANCE. SENATOR DODD THE
FLOOR'S YOURS. I THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I
PRESENTE- AB THREE OH ONE TWO
ON BEHALF ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
ONE OF THE MANY MANY CHANGES
BROUGHT ON BY THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN WILDFIRES IS
A SIGNIFICANT DISRUPTION THE
CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNERS INSURANCE
MARKET. SINCE 200-017-0002
CALIFORNIA BEEN NON RENEWED BY
THEIR INSURANCE PROVIDERS AND
FORCED ONTO A VERY- EXPENSIVE
FAIR PLANNED WE KNOW THIS
CONTINUE TO HAPPEN AS A RESULT
THE FIRES THIS YEAR THIS AB
THREE OH TWO IS NOT A SILVER
BULLET BUT I THINK IT'S A
SERIES OF BALLOTS STEPS IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. THIS BILL IS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DRIVERS.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ONE TIME. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES
BELL. FORGES BRADFORD HI
CABRERA I CHIANG DALLY DOT.
FIVE TERRAZZA I GALGIANI I
GLAZER. GONZALEZ I GROWTH
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO. I
HER TADO I JACKSON HI I JONES
LEYVA. I MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ
MITCHELL HI MY NAME I MORLOCK
GIRL NIELSEN I PAN I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH I RUBIO I SKINNER STERN
I AM BURKE I Y. CASKEY I WIENER
AYE WILK. SENATOR SENATOR DODD
MOVES TO CALL MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM THIRTY TWO SENATOR
GONZALEZ. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE REACH. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE THIRTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEBER AND AFTER
LEADING THE COURTS CENTER
CONSOLES THE FLOOR'S YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS TODAY RISE
AND RISE TO PRESENT AB TWO
THREE THREE EIGHT ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER WHICH
WILL ADDRESS THE MISALIGNMENT
AND CAN'T CALIFORNIA'S PENAL
AND CIVIL CODES AS IT RELATES
TO CONTENT IN FAMILY COURT
PROCEEDINGS SPECIFICALLY THIS
BILL WILL PROVIDE PROBATION AS
AN ADDITIONAL AND ALTERNATIVE
SENTENCING OPTIONS WHEN AN
INDIVIDUAL IS FOUND IN CONTEMPT
OF FAMILY LAW COURT ORDER OR
JUDGMENT. UNDER CURRENT LAW
FAMILY COURT JUDGES ARE ONLY
ALLOWED TO IMPOSE COMMUNITY
SERVICE OR IMPRISONMENT FOR NO
MORE THAN FIVE DAYS FOR
INDIVIDUALS FOUND IN CONTEMPT
AND PROVIDES ZERO JUDICIAL
DISCRETION WITH THIS PUNISHMENT
MULTIPLE KIDS ACCOUNTS OF
CONTEMPT FOR FAILURE TO PAY
CHILD SUPPORT WILL ADD UP OVER
TIME FOR INSTANCE FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO LIVE PAYCHECK
TO PAYCHECK AND IT WOULD BE
MORE PRUDENT TO INSTEAD ALLOW
THESE INDIVIDUALS. TO BE ON
PROBATION AND WORK TOWARD
MEETING THEIR FINANCIAL
OBLIGATIONS OF RESPECTFULLY ASK
HER AYE VOTE THANK YOU DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THE SIDE
SEEING AND HEARING ON MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ONE TIME. ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS. BATES BELL PORGES
BRADFORD I HAVE A I CHIANG
DALLY DODD. I DRAWS A I
GALGIANI I GLAZER GONZALEZ I
GROWTH HERTZBERG AYE HILL ALL
RIGHT HI WITH SO. HI HER TADO I
JACKSON HI I JONES LEYVA. AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ MITCHELL I
MONEY. I MORLOCK. ZERO NIELSEN.
PAN. FIVE AYE ROTH I RUBIO. HI
SKINNER. STERN HI I'M BURKE
RIGHT HI MY COUNTY I WIENER AYE
WILK. SOONER GONZALEZ MOVES TO
CALL FOR COULD HAVE ONE MOMENT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INDULGENCE
COLLEGE WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NOW
TO FILE ITEM THIRTY NINE FILE
ITEM THIRTY NINE SENATOR PER
TITLE. BEN SCHECHTER PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
THREE SEVENTY ONE BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON VETERANS
AFFAIRS AND ACTUALLY
INDIFFERENCE SENATOR PER TITLE
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I'M
HERE TO PRESENT AB THIRTY THREE
SEVENTY ONE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN AND THE
VETERANS AFFAIRS COMMITTEE THIS
BILL WILL AMEND THE DATA
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS OF THE
ANNUAL SUICIDES AMONG VETERANS
AND CAL AND THE CALIFORNIA
REPORTS. THE FIRST REPORT
RELEASED IN MAY OF TWENTY
NINETEEN CONTAINED ONLY TWO
PAGES THE SECOND REPORT
RELEASED IN JUNE OF THIS YEAR
WAS DOUBLE THE LENGTH OF THE
FIRST AT AT ONLY FOUR PAGES THE
RIPPLES CONTAIN INSUFFICIENT
DATA TO DRAW ANY CONCLUSIONS OR
INFERENCES WHICH BECOME
DIFFICULT TO TAKE ACTION OR
IMPLEMENT POLICY AB THREE THREE
SEVEN ONE AMEND THE DATA
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS TOGETHER
FOR THEIR DEMOGRAPHICS
INFORMATION AND TO COMPARE
CURRENT AND PAST DATA. SUICIDE
IS A TRAGIC PUBLIC HEALTH
PROBLEM THAT CAN AND SHOULD BE
PREVENTED BY INCREASES IN
AWARENESS AND SUITABLE
TREATMENT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM SEEING
AND HEARING ON MADAM. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ONE TIME.
OUR I ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
BATES BELL. FOR JUST BRADFORD
HI CABALLERO FIVE CHIANG ALLEY
DODD. I TERRAZZA I GALGIANI
FIVE GLAZER GONZALEZ HI GROVE
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO. I
HER TADO HI JACKSON ALL RIGHT I
JONES LEYVA. I MCGUIRE I
MELENDEZ MITCHELL I MONEY I
MORLOCK MORALE NIELSEN. I PAN
AYE PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO.
FIVE SKINNER STERN AYE NUMBER I
WHITE HOUSE SKI HI WIENER I
WILK. SENATOR FURTADO MOVES A
CALL. OUR NEXT ITEM UP IS. FILE
ITEM. FORTY GONNA PASS ON THAT
FILE ITEM FORTY THREE. FILE
ITEM FORTY THREE SENATOR HILL.
OH I'M SORRY SENATOR HILL. OKAY
ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
I'M SORRY WE
HAVE LITTLE CONFUSION HERE
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO FILE
ITEM FORTY FILE ITEM FORTY.
SENATOR NIELSEN MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GALLAGHER AND
ACTUALLY INTO HOMELESSNESS.
SENATOR NIELSEN THE FLOOR'S
YOURS. MOMENT. BILL DOES RELATE.
TO THE COUNTIES OF YUBA AND
SUTTER. TO ALLOW THEM TO
JOINTLY ESTABLISH. AND HOMELESS
ADULT AND FAMILY MULTI
DISCIPLINARY PERSONNEL TEAM.
THIS WOULD ALLOW THEN MULTI
DISCIPLINED TEAM TO HELP
INTERVENE AND BE OF ASSISTANCE
TO THOSE WHO ARE HOMELESS. THAT
THEY MIGHT IMPROVE THEIR STATUS.
HE TO BECOMING HOUSING EMPLOYED
MORE SAFELY LOCATED I WOULD ASK
AN AYE VOTE IT DOES APPLY TO
JUST YUBA AND SUTTER COUNTIES.
THANKS THANK YOU CENTER NIELSEN
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING AND HEARING NON
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ONE TIME. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES
BELL FOR JUST BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO. I CHIANG DALLY DOT
HI TERRAZZA I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER GONZALEZ I GROWTH
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO. I
HER TADO. I JACKSON BYE BYE
JONES LEYVA. FIVE MCGUIRE AYE
MELINDA'S MITCHELL. I MORNING.
WARLOCK GIRL NIELSEN I CAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. NO RUBIO.
I SKINNER. STERN HI I'M BURKE
ALL RIGHT HI MY COUNTY. FIVE
WIENER. HI WILK. SENATOR
NIELSEN MOVES TO CALL MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM FORTY THREE NOW
SENATOR HILL THE FLOOR'S YOURS
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE
SEVENTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEVINE AND ACTUALLY INTO
EMPLOYMENT AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THERE OF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR HILL.
PAPERS IT AB THIRTY ONE SEVENTY
FIVE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVINE THIS BILL IS A
TECHNICAL CLEAN UP THAT WOULD
CLARIFY SEXUAL HARASSMENT
PREVENTION AND RETALIATION
TRAINING BE COMPLETED BY AN AGE
ELIGIBLE MINOR ACCOMPANIED BY.
A PARENT OR GUARDIAN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL
COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ONE TIME. ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES BELL PORGES
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I CHIANG.
DALLY DODD. FIVE TORONTO.
GALGIANI I GLAZER GONZALEZ I
GROWTH HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO. HI HER TADO HI JACKSON
HI I JONES LEYVA. I MCGUIRE I
MELENDEZ MITCHELL. I MONEY. I
MORLOCK MORALE NIELSEN. PAM I
PORTANTINO I ROTH FIVE RUBIO. I
SKINNER STERN HI I'M BURKE HI
MY COUNTY AYE WIENER HI WILK.
SENATOR HILL MOVED TO CALL
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM FORTY
FIVE SENATOR AKOWSKI YOU
PREPARED TO TAKE UP THIS ITEM.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL. TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTEEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CHAO AN ACTUAL LEADING TO
UNATTENDED CHILDREN. SENATOR
RICK WHY COUNTY YES MADAM A
PRESIDENT THIS BILL WILL EXEMPT
THE CIVIL AND CRIMINAL
LIABILITIES FOR GOOD SAMARITANS
THAT RESCUE CHILDREN UNDER THE
AGE OF SIX LEFT UNATTENDED
FROM- FROM A VEHICLE IF THERE'S
AN IMMEDIATE DANGER OF
SUFFERING HARM AND IF EMERGENCY
SERVICES SERVICES HAVE BEEN
CONTACTED. PRIOR TO THE RESCUE
I REGION AYE VOTE THANK CENTER
Y. QUE TO BE DISCO ON THIS ITEM
SEEING AND HEARING NONE BATUM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WANT. ALLEN I ACTUALLY. AYE
ATKINS. I FACE FELL GORGEOUS
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I CHIANG
DALLY DODD. I DRAWS A- I
GALGIANI I GLAZER GONZALEZ I
GROWTH HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO. I HER TADO I JACKSON HI
I JONES LEYVA. FIVE MCGUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ MITCHELL. I MONEY I
MORLOCK MORALE NIELSEN. PAN I
PORTANTINO. I ROTH FIVE RUBIO.
I SKINNER STERN I AM BURKE
RIGHT HI MY COUNTY I WIENER AYE
WILK. SENATOR AKOWSKI MOVES TO
COLD MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
FORTY SIX FILE ITEM FORTY SIX
SENATOR DOORASHO ARE YOU
PREPARED TO TAKE UP THIS ITEM.
FILE ITEM FORTY SIX MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY THREE TWENTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER AND
ACTUALLY IN THE JUVENILE COURT
RECORDS SENATOR TO RUSSELL
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY ONE. VOIGTS
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S ABILITY TO
ACCESS SEALED JUVENILE RECORDS
IN THEIR POSITION POSSESSION
WITH THE SOLE PURPOSE OF
PROCESSING ARE YOU FOR T. VISA.
THESE VISAS ALLOW INDIVIDUALS
TO LEGALLY REMAIN WITHIN THE
UNITED STATES IF YOU'RE A
VICTIM OF A CRIME OR WERE
HELPFUL IN THE INVESTIGATION OF
A CRIME. FOR A U. AND T. VISA
TO BE PROCESSED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. A LAW ENFORCEMENT
ENTITY INCLUDING A DISTRICT
ATTORNEY MUST CERTIFY UNDER
PENALTY OF PERJURY IN FEDERAL
COURT. THAT THE UNDOCUMENTED
INDIVIDUAL WAS THE VICTIM OF A
CRIME OR HELPFUL DURING THE
INVESTIGATION. HOWEVER IN SOME
INSTANCES WHEN AN APPLICANT
COMES FORWARD A DISTRICT
ATTORNEY IS UNABLE TO CERTIFY
THE APPLICATION BECAUSE THE
JUVENILE RECORDS ARE SEALED AND
CANNOT BE US ACCESS TO. THIS
BILL STRIKES AN IMPORTANT
BALANCE BY PRESERVING THE
RIGHTS OF THE JUVENILE
DEFENDANTS AND MAKING CLEAR
THAT RECORDS MAY ONLY BE
ACCESSED FOR THE SOLE PURPOSE
OF CERTIFYING A U. OR T. VISA
APPLICATION. DOES HELPING THAT
INDIVIDUAL THAT IS THE VICTIM
OF A CRIME REMAIN IN THIS
COUNTRY WITHOUT FEAR OF
DEPORTATION. THIS BILL IS
SPONSORED BY THE LOS ANGELES
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND
WAS RECENTLY AMENDED TO PROCESS
CHAPTER IN OUT AMENDMENTS WITH
SB ELEVEN TWENTY SIX HAS NO
OPPOSITION NBC BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. IN THE SENATE PUBLIC
SAFETY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR
ROGERS FOR ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THE SIDE. SEEING
AND HEARING ON MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ONE TIME.
WITH ALAN. I ARCHULETA. I
ATKINS I BATES BELL FOR JUST
BRADFORD I HAVE A I CHIANG
DALLY DODD. FIVE TERRAZZA I
GALGIANI I GLAZER GONZALEZ I
GROWTH HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO. I HER TADO I JACKSON I
JONES LEYVA. I MCGUIRE I
MELINDA'S MITCHELL I MONEY.
FIVE WARLOCK MORALE NIELSEN.
PAN FIVE PORTANTINO HI RALPH.
FIVE RUBIO I SKINNER STERN I AM
BURKE FIVE WACO SKI I WIENER. I
WILK SENATOR RUSSELL MOVED TO
CALL MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
FIFTY ONE SENATOR PAN ARE YOU
PREPARED ON THE SIDE BOTTOM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY ONE THIRTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW AND ACTUALLY
INTO PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS.
SENATOR PAM THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SENATORS- THIS BILL
AB TWENTY TWENTY ONE THIRTEEN
BY SOME MEMBER LOW REQUIRES
PROFESSIONAL LICENSING BOARDS
UNDER DEPARTMENT CONSUMER
AFFAIRS TO EXPEDITE LICENSE
APPLICATIONS FOR REFUGEES.
ASSEMBLIES AND SPECIAL
IMMIGRANT VISA HOLDERS THIS
BILL PROVIDES AN IMPORTANT
ECONOMIC TOOL FOR REFUGEES BY
REQUIRING PROFESSIONAL BOARDS
TO EXPEDITE THE LICENSE
APPLICATION REFUGEES CAN OBTAIN
STABLE EMPLOYMENT AS BARBERS
LOCATIONAL NURSES PRIVATE
SECURITY IN OTHER FIELDS MUCH
QUICKER. THIS IS ESPECIALLY
RELEVANT NOW AS THE CORONA
VIRUS PANDEMIC HAS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
REFUGEES AND IMMIGRANTS AB
TWENTY ONE THIRTEEN IS A
PRIORITY LEGISLATION AT THE
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS HAS NO
FORMAL OPPOSITION EXPECT THE
ASPIRIN I'D LIKE TO DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM SEEING
AND HEARING ON MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON TIME.
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES BELL FOR JUST BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO I CHIANG DALLY DODD.
FIVE TERRAZZA I GALGIANI FIVE
GLAZER GONZALEZ I GROWTH
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO. I
HER TADO. I JACKSON I JONES
LEYVA. I MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S
MITCHELL. I MONNING AYE MORLOCK
MORALE NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH. FIVE RUBIO.
HI SKINNER STERN I NUMBER FIVE
LAKE COUNTY I WINNER. I WILK
SENATOR PAN MOVES TO CALL
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM SIXTY
SENATOR BRADFORD MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT FORTY SIX BY
ASSEMLYMEMBER BURKE AND
ACTUALLY TO PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
SENATOR BRADFORD THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AB. EIGHT FOUR
SIX BY ASSEMBLYWOMAN AUTUMN
BURKE AND MR IRWIN WILL DEVELOP
A PROCESS TO EVALUATE NEW PEACE
OFFICERS IN CALIFORNIA FOR
IMPLICIT AND EXPLICIT BIAS THAT
COULD MAKE THEM UNFIT TO
PERFORM THEIR DUTIES IN
ADDITION THIS BILL REQUIRE
DEPARTMENTS TO DE EMPHASIZE THE
PROBLEM. MILITARY ASPECTS OF
THE JOB AND RECRUIT GROUPEMENT
MATERIALS AND INSTEAD HIGHLIGHT
COMMUNITY INTERACTION AND
COLLABORATIVE PROBLEM SOLVING
AS WE'VE SEEN IN RECENT MONTHS
OUR NATION IS. GRAPPLING WITH
POLICE AGAIN AND ITS LEGACY
WITHIN THE BLACK COMMUNITY WE
NEED SYSTEMIC CHANGE WITHIN LAW-ENFORCEMENT AND PART OF THAT
TASK INCLUDES CHANGING THE
CULTURE WAS A RECENT FBI STUDY
THAT STATED. BY THE LARGEST
RECRUITMENT OF WHITE
SUPREMACISTS AND KKK HAS BEEN
IN LAW ENFORCEMENT OF THE LAWS
TEN YEARS. THIS CAN BE IN A WAY
THAT WE RECRUIT EVALUATE AND RE
FRAME THE POSITION OF POTENTIAL
APPLICANTS AND A LOT OF THE
LATEST ACTS OF POLICE
BRUTALITY. ESPECIALLY THE
COWARDLY ACT OF SHOOTING MR
BLAKE'S SEVEN TIMES IN HIS BACK
AND NATION WIDE CALLS FOR
REFORM CALIFORNIA MUST ACT
INDIVIDUALS WITH RACIAL AND
OTHER DISCRIMINATORY BIASES IN
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE LOOKING TO
USE VIOLENCE. OR PROVE. OUR
POWER TO HARM OTHERS SHOULD NOT
BE QUALIFIED RECRUITED TO JOIN
LAW ENFORCEMENT. THIS PROPOSED
CHANGES WILL SIGNIFICANTLY
REFORM HOW PEACE OFFICERS ARE
RECRUITED HIRED AND DEEM FIT TO
PROTECT. OUR STATE DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT MY RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM SEEING AND HEARING NON
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ONE TIME. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES
WELL GORGEOUS BRADFORD I HAVE A
ADAM I CHAN. DALLY DOT I
TORONTO I GOT JOHNNY I GLAZER
GONZALEZ. I GROWTH HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO. I HER TADO.
JACKSON HI I JONES LEYVA. HI
WIRE. FIVE MELENDEZ MITCHELL. I
MONEY FIVE MORLOCK MORALE
NIELSEN HI PAM I PORTANTINO I
ROTH. HI RUBIO I SKINNER STERN
HI AMBERG I LIKE HOUSEKI I
WIENER AYE WILK SENATOR. HER
TADO I'D SENATOR BRADFORD MOVES
TO CALL MOVING ON NOW TO FILE
ITEM SIXTY ONE FILE ITEM SIXTY
ONE SENATOR DODD MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FOUR FIFTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON AN ACT
RELATING TO AIR AMBULANCE
SERVICES AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THERE OF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY SENATOR DAHLE MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I'M
PLEASED TO REPRESENT YOU AB
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY BY CENTER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON WHICH
WILL ENSURE THAT AIMLESS.
PROVIDERS CONTINUE TO RECEIVE
FUNDING FOR THEIR OPERATIONS
EMERGENCY AIR AMBULANCE
PROVIDERS PLAY A KEY ROLE IN
HOMELAND SECURITY AND DISASTER
RESPONSE INCLUDING EVACUATING
HOSPITALS IN THE PATH OF WILD
FIRES RESPONDING THE CODE
NINETEEN REQUESTS. AB TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY SIMPLY EXTENDS THE
EMERGENCY MEDICAL AIR
TRANSPORTATION ACT UNTIL JULY
FIRST TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE
TO PRESERVE THE SERVICES BILLS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN THE NOW
SUPPORT RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THE
SIDE. SEEING AND HEARING ON
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ONE TIME. ALLEN HI I.
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
WELL GORGEOUS BRADFORD. CUT CUT
BY OTHER I CHIANG DALLY DODD HI
THERE I WASN'T. I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER GONZALEZ I GROWTH
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO. I
HER TADO I JACKSON WELL I JONES
LEYVA. I MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S
MITCHELL I MONEY I MORLOCK.
WELL YEAH. I PAN FIVE
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO. I
SKINNER STERN I- BURKE I LIKE
HOW TO SKI. HI WIENER I WILK
SENATOR DODD MOVES TO CALL
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM SIXTY
FIVE FILE ITEM SIXTY FIVE
CENTER ABALLERO MADAM SECTOR
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY NINE SIXTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON AND
ACTUALLY NEED TO SHELTERS
CENTER KABIR THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I. THIS BILL WOULD
GIVE THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
MORE FLEXIBILITY TO ESTABLISH
TEMPORARY HOMELESS SHELTERS IN
EXISTING BUILDINGS AND REQUIRES
THOSE PLANS TO BE APPROVED BY
THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL BEFORE
BEING UTILIZED FIRST CITY THAT
WANTS TO ESTABLISH A TEMPORARY
HOMELESS SHELTER IN AN EXISTING
BUILDING. THIS AUTOMATICALLY
TRIGGERS A CHANGE IN USE AND
REQUIRE SEISMIC AND SPRINKLER
SYSTEM SYSTEM RETROFITS THIS
CAN COST ANYWHERE FROM TEN
THOUSAND TO MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY BUILT ON
EXISTING LAW TO GIVE THESE
CITIES LOS ANGELES A WAY TO
FIND REASONABLE AND COST
EFFECTIVE ALTERNATIVES TO THE-
TO THE SHELTER SHELTERS
OPERATIONAL OPERATIONS AND HELP
MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR STATE'S
HOMELESS CRISIS THE BILL HAS
ENJOYED UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. AND HAS NO OPPOSITION
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM SEEING AND HEARING ON
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ONE TIME. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES
BEL BURGESS BRADFORD. CABALLERO
I CHIANG DALLY DODD I
TERRORIZER I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER GONZALEZ. I GROWTH
HERTZBERG. HILL AYE HUESO I HER
TADO I JACKSON I JONES LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE. I MELENDEZ MITCHELL
FIVE MONNING THANKS I MORE LOCK
MORALE NIELSEN HI PAM I
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. I RUBIO I
SKINNER TURN I NUMBER FIVE
WHITE HOUSE SKI. I WIENER AYE
WILK SENATOR CAFIERO MOVES TO
CALL MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
SIXTY SIX SENATOR GALGIANI
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT THIRTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER EGGMAN
AND ACTUALLY NEED TO FLOOD
MANAGEMENT CENTER GALGIANI
OAKLAND FOR NUMBERS AB EIGHT
THIRTY EIGHT EXTEND A DEADLINE
BY THREE YEARS. FOR THE FAMILY.
AREA FLOOD CONTROL AGENCY TO
COMPLETE A TWO HUNDRED YEAR
FLOOD CONTROL SYSTEM WITHIN THE
MOSTEL TRACK LOCATED IN SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY. AB EIGHT THIRTY
EIGHT PROVIDES THIS ONE TIME
THREE YEAR EXTENSION IN ORDER
TO PROTECT THE PROPERTY AND
RESIDENTS WITHIN MY STILL
TRAPPED THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
NO OPPOSITION AND HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SEEING AND
HEARING ON MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ONE TIME.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS
I BATES WELL OR JUST BRADFORD
CABALLERO I CHIANG DALLY DODD I
DRAWS A- GALGIANI I GLAZER
GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO. I HER TADO
I JACKSON HI I JONES LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ MITCHELL.
I MONEY I MORLOCK MORALE
NIELSEN. I CAN I PORTANTINO I
ROTH. I RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN
HI I'M BURKE I WHITE HOUSE SKI
FIVE WIENER. I WILK SENATOR
GALGIANI MOVES TO CALL MOVING
ON NOW TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY
FIVE COLLEAGUES FILE ITEM
SEVENTY FIVE. SENATOR SKINNER
ARE YOU READY RIGHT WITH THAT
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES
SAWYER AND ACTUALLY DID A
HARASSMENT SENATOR SKINNER
FLOORS YOU. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS WE ARE
ALL FAMILIAR WITH SITUATIONS
WHERE SOMEONE HAS
INAPPROPRIATELY CALLED NINE ONE
ONE. TO HARASS OR OTHERWISE.
INAPPROPRIATELY CALL NINE ONE
ONE OR IT GETS A PERSON OF
COLOR. FOR EXAMPLE- WE'VE ALL
FROM SURE SHOT THE REPORTS
AROUND THE. BLACK MAN WHO WAS
BIRD WATCHING IN CENTRAL PARK
AND A WHITE WOMAN. FAKED AN
ENTIRE A THREAT THAT SHE
CLAIMED HE WAS MAKING THE CALL
TO NINE ONE ONE. THERE ARE MANY
MANY INCIDENTS IN CALIFORNIA IN
MY OWN DISTRICT- FOLKS WERE
BARBECUING AND- A WOMAN CALLED
NINE ONE ONE BECAUSE THEY WERE
BARBECUING. SO WE'VE HAD MANY
INSTANCES LIKE THIS WHAT THIS
BILL DOES. IS ADDRESS THE
MISUSE OF NINE ONE ONE WHEN IT
IS USED SPECIFICALLY AS A
HARASSMENT TOOL. ORDER PURPORTS
TO RESULT IN A FALSE POLICE
REPORT AIMED AT HARASSING. A
PERSON BASED ON EITHER THEIR
SKIN COLOR OR ONE OF THE OTHER
PROTECTED CHARACTERISTICS AND
WHAT IT DOES IS IMPOSES A FINE
FOR A MISDEMEANOR ON A PERSON
WHO KNOWINGLY USES NINE ONE ONE
FOR THIS PURPOSE. AND PROVIDES
ENHANCED PENALTIES FOR
KNOWINGLY MAKING FALSE NINE ONE
ONE CALLS AND A MEMBER OF A
PROTECTED CLASS IN IT CLARIFIES
IN CIVIL CODE THAT THE FALSE
REPORT TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
TARGETING ANOTHER IS NOT A
PRIVILEGED COMMUNICATION WHICH
THUS ALLOWS THE FALSE REPORT TO
BE USED AS EVIDENCE. AND A
COUPLE OF OTHER- MINOR MORE
MINOR ITEMS THERE'S BROAD
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL AMONGST
EMERGENCY SYSTEM OPERATORS LAW
ENFORCEMENT SOCIAL WORKERS
DISABILITY ADVOCATES AND OTHERS
IT'S HAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM DEBATER DISCUSSION
CHING IN HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ONE TIME. ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES BELL GORGEOUS
BRADFORD CABALLERO I CHIANG
DALLY DOT. FIVE TORONTO I
GALGIANI I GLAZER GONZALEZ I
GROWTH HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO. I HER TADO. HI JACKSON
WHY I JONES LEYVA. AYE MCGUIRE
AYE MELENDEZ MITCHELL I MONEY.
FIVE MORLOCK MORALE NIELSEN
FIVE PAN FIVE PORTANTINO. I
ROTH I RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN
HI I'M BURKE HI HI HI KASKI I
WIENER. FIVE WILK SENATOR
SKINNER MOVES TO CALL MOVING ON
NOW TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY SEVEN.
SENATOR STERN BACK THERE IN THE
CORNER YOU READY. ALL RIGHT
WITH THAT MATTER MOST SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EGGMAN AND
ACTUALLY TO MENTAL HEALTH.
SENATOR STERN FLOOR'S YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
MIRZAI RIGHTS RESENT AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX WHICH
UPDATES AND EXPANDS SOME
ASPECTS OF LAURA'S LAW ALSO
KNOWN AS ASSISTED OUTPATIENT
TREATMENT LAURA'S LAWS EVIDENCE
BASED COMMUNITY BASED-
PROVIDING TREATMENT OF THOSE
WHO MAY OTHERWISE BE ABLE
UNABLE TO ACCESS COMMUNITY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
VOLUNTARILY DUE TO THEIR SEVERE
MENTAL ILLNESS THIS BILL WOULD
EXPAND THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
ASSISTED OUTPATIENT TREATMENT
STATEWIDE WHILE PROVIDING
COUNTIES FLEXIBILITY TO OPT OUT
TO RESOLUTION BY THEIR BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX WILL ALSO ALLOW
COUNTIES THE OPTION TO
COLLABORATE WITH EACH OTHER TO
IMPLEMENT THE LAW WHILE
REQUIRING THAT THEY COME TO A
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING
THAT ENSURES ACCOUNTABILITY.
FOR PATIENT CARE. THIS BILL
ALSO REPEALS THE SUNSET DATE.
AFTER EIGHTEEN YEARS OF
CONTINUED IMPLEMENTATION. THIS
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT REALLY IS
A DEMONSTRATION PROJECT NO MORE
IT IS PROVEN SUCCESSFUL- AND
THE LAW STILL REQUIRES THIS
REGULAR REPORTING. WELL WE'RE
EXPERIENCING TODAY IS A MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS IN OUR SOCIETY WE
CAN'T JUST BE ADDRESSED THROUGH
ONE MEANS. WOULD BLAME PEOPLE
BUT OFTEN THE SYSTEM ITSELF CAN
ACCOMMODATE THOSE WHO NEED THE
TREATMENT MOST WE RECYCLE
PEOPLE THROUGH OUR SYSTEMS WE
BRING THEM INTO CONSERVATORSHIP
OR INTO THE CARE OF THE WARSHIP
OF THE COUNTY OR THE STATE. A
STATE AUDIT RECENTLY SHOWED
THAT THOSE PEOPLE OFTEN END UP
BACK OUT ON THE STREETS
MULTIPLE TIMES IN THEIR LIVES
SOMETIMES TEN TIMES OR MORE
THIS WASTE MONEY. BUT ALSO
TREATS PEOPLE INHUMANELY WE
THINK THIS BILL IS AN IMPORTANT
RESPONSE TO THIS AUDIT REPORT
ADDRESSING THE ISSUE IN A
HUMANE MANNER AND REALLY BRINGS
COUNTY. LET A GOVERNMENT INTO A
PLACE OF PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR
STATE IN THIS. EFFORT TO END
MENTAL HEALTH CRISES ON OUR
STREETS THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SENATOR STERN DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM SEEING
AND HEARING ON MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ONE TIME.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES FELL FOR JUST
BRADFORD BY ADAM I CHIANG DALLY
DODD. HI THERE ASA HI GALGIANI
I GLAZER GONZALEZ I GROWTH
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI HER TADO BY JACKSON HI I
JONES LEYVA. FIVE MCGUIRE FIVE
MELENDEZ MITCHELL. HI MY NAME
FIVE MORLOCK GIRL NIELSEN HI
PAM FIVE PORTANTINO I ROTH FIVE
RUBIO. HI SKINNER. I STERN HI
I'M BURKE I LIKE HOW SKI HI
WIENER. I WILK SENATOR STERN
MOVES TO CALL SENATOR NIELSEN.
FOR WHAT PURPOSE CERTAIN. THE
MATTER PRESIDENT BASED ON THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
REPUBLICAN MEMBERS WILL NOT
ONLY BE ABLE TO VOTE REMOTELY
TOMORROW. BUT THEY CAN DEBATE
AS WELL I WILL WITHDRAW MY
MOTION RELATED TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AND I. IF YOU LIKE I'D
RECITE THE I'LL JUST LEAVE
THESE ITEMS OF THE DESK SO WE
DON'T REPEAT THAT WOULD BE FINE
THAT IS ACCEPTABLE AGAIN BOTH
THE CONSENT AND THE SPECIAL
CONCERN IS CORRECT VERY GOOD IF
YOU BRING THOSE UP TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE. ACROSS ALL OUR
TEAS AND DARTED ALL OUR EYES TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN. MUCH
APPRECIATED. THANK YOU MOVING
ON NOW TO A FILE ITEM SEVENTY
EIGHT SENATOR PAN EXCUSE ME.
SEVENTY EIGHT YES SENATOR PAN
PARDON ME MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN NINETY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COME LOCKER AND
ACTUALLY INTO UNEMPLOYMENT
COMPENSATION AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THERE US TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY SENATOR PAM THANK
YOU MADAM PRESENCE AT ANDERS
HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON
EIGHTY NINETEEN NINETY THREE BY
SOME MEMBER COME LOCKER THE
FAMILY CAREGIVER ECONOMIC
SUPPORT SECURITY ACT. UNDER
CURRENT LAW ALTHOUGH EMPLOYEES.
IN HOME SUPPORT SERVICES
PROVIDERS WHO CARE FOR A
DISABLED CHILD OR SPOUSE ARE
NOT ELIGIBLE FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE. SO ABOUT A HUNDRED
TWENTY ONE THOUSAND I HSS
PROVIDERS MOSTLY WOMEN FALL
INTO THIS CATEGORY. THEY MAY
BECOME UNEMPLOYED DUE TO DEATH
OR HOSPITALIZATION OF THE LOVED
ONE THAT LEAVES THEM SUFFERING
LOSS BOTH EMOTIONALLY AND
FINANCIALLY SO THEY DON'T GET
UNEMPLOYMENT. I URGE MY
COLLEAGUES TO VOTE FOR AB
NINETEEN NINETY THREE TO EXTEND
UNEPLOYMENT INSURANCE
ELIGIBILITY TO PARENT AND
SPOUSE HSS AND WPCS PROVIDERS
ARE TYPICALLY ASKED WHEN I DID.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
FILE ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT SEEING
AND HEARING NOT. BEEN CHECKED
HER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ONE
TIME. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BATES BEL BURGESS
BRADFORD CABALLERO I CHIANG
DALLY DODD. I TERRAZZA.
GALGIANI I GLAZER GONZALEZ I
GROWTH HERTZBERG HI HILL AYE
HUESO I HER TADO HI JACKSON HI
I JONES. LEYVA FIVE MCGUIRE. I
MELENDEZ MITCHELL. HI MY NAME I
MORE LOCK. ZERO NIELSEN. PAN I
PORTANTINO FIVE ROTH FIVE RUBIO
I SKINNER. I STERN AYE AMBERG I
WHITE HOUSE SKI FIVE WIENER. HI
WILK. SENATOR PAN MOVES TO CALL
MOVING ON COLLEAGUES TO FILE
ITEM EIGHTY FIVE FILE ITEM
EIGHTY FIVE SENATOR GALGIANI.
WE WILL PASS TEMPORARILY AND
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY SIX
SENATOR CAFIERO MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW AND ACTUALLY
TO HEALING ARTS AND DECLARING
THE URGENCY THERE US TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY CENTER
CABALLERO THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
2% AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW WHICH PROVIDES TEMPORARY
FLEXIBILITY TO ADDRESS AN
IMMEDIATE PROBLEM CREATED BY
THE COAL BED NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
THAT PREVENTS NURSING STUDENTS
FROM GAINING CLINICAL
EXPERIENCE NECESSARY TO
COMPLETE THEIR EDUCATION
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL ALLOWS
NURSING STUDENTS TO UTILIZE
CLINICAL SIMULATION UP 275% IN
THREE SPECIALTY AREAS WHICH ARE
WELL SUITED TO THE SIMULATION
ALLOWS THE THEORY AND THE
CLINICAL TRAINING TO BE TAKEN
IN CONSECUTIVE TERMS RATHER
THAN CONCURRENTLY WHICH IS
REQUIRED. THE BILL IS NARROWLY
TERREL TAILORED AND
INCORPORATES TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION THE AUTHOR
WORKED CLOSELY WITH THE SCHOOLS
AS THEY PLANNED FOR THE FALL
WINTER AND SPRING TERMS AND
ENJOYS THE SUPPORT AND THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE C. ISSUES AND
YOU SEE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM IS
THERE ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SEEING AND HEARING ON MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ONE TIME. ALLEN I ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS AYE BATES BELL. PORGES
BRADFORD CABALLERO I CHIANG
DALLY DODD. I TERRAZZA.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH HERTZBERGI
HILL AYE HUESO. I HER TADO HI
JACKSON. HI I JONES LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE. I WILL AND MITCHELL. I
MONEY I MORLOCK MORALE NIELSEN
I PAN I PORTANTINO. I ROTH I
RUBIO. I SKINNER HI STERN I AM
BURKE HI HI CASKEY I WIENER AYE
WILK. SENATE REPUBLICAN ERA
MOVES TO CALL MOVING ON NOW TO
FILE ITEM NINETY SIX FILE ITEM
NINETY SIX SENATOR HILL MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY ONE FIFTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA AND
ACTUALLY LEADING TO PUBLIC
HEALTH SENATOR HILL THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AB TWENTY ONE
FIFTY TWO BELLA'S ACT WILL
FURTHER THE STATE'S EFFORTS TO
INCREASE ADOPTIONS OF RESCUE
ANIMALS AND PROTECT ANIMAL
WELFARE BY CLOSING THE LOOPHOLE
IN CURRENT LAW PROHIBITING THE
RETAIL SALE OF DOGS CATS AND
RABBITS FROM PUPPY MILLS.
RECENT AMENDMENTS REMOVED ALL
OPPOSITION FROM THE BILL OVER
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL COLLEGE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM SEEING AND HEARING ON
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ONE TIME. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES.
TELL FOR JUST BRADFORD
CABALLERO I CHIANG ALLEY DODD.
I TERRAZZA I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH
HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO. I
HER TADO HI JACKSON I JONES
LEYVA I MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ
MITCHELL. FIVE MONNING I
MORLOCK MORALE NIELSEN AYE PAN
AYE PORTANTINO. I ROTH HI RUBIO
I SKINNER. I STERN I AM VERY HI
MY COUNTY HI WIENER. FIVE WILK
SENATOR HILL MOVES TO CALL
MOVING ON NOW TO FILE ITEM
NINETY SEVEN FILE ITEM NINETY
SEVEN SENATOR DODD. DO YOU WISH
TO TAKE UP THE SIDE OF. WITHOUT
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
FILE ITEM NINETY SEVEN.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE THIRTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAY AND
ACTUALLY DEAN TO ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THERE OF SICK AFFECT
MEDIALLY. SENATOR DODD THE
FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. AB THIRTY
ONE THIRTY NINE MODIFIES THE
RULES RELATING TO AN ON SALE
ALCOHOL BEVERAGE LICENSE USE OF
AN ALTERNATE LOCATION WHILE THE
LICENSEE REBUILDS REPAIRS THE
ORIGINAL LICENSE LOCATION
FOLLOWING A FIRE RATHER ACT OF
GOD- THERE'S NO OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL I ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM SEEING AND HEARING ON
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ONE TIME. WITH ALLEN. AYE
ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
BELL FOR JUST BRADFORD
CABALLERO I CHIANG DALLY DODD.
I TERASA I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
I GONZALEZ I GROWTH HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO. HI HER TADO.
I JACKSON WHY I JONES LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ MITCHELL.
I MONEY. I MORLOCK MORALE
NIELSEN. HAM AYE PORTANTINO I.
ROSS I RUBIO. I SKINNER I STERN
KASKI AYE WIENER AYE WILK
SENATOR DODD MOVES TO CALL
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
HUNDRED SENATOR HERTZBERG MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN TWENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER AND
ACTUALLY TO CANNABIS SENATOR
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU THIS
MEASURE WILL EXPAND ACCESS TO
BANKING AND OTHER FINANCIAL
SERVICES. FOR THE CASH BASED
CANNABIS INDUSTRY. GIVEN THE
EXTRAORDINARY CONFLICT BETWEEN
STATE AND FEDERAL LAW ON THE
USE OF CANNABIS. ONLY SEVEN
HUNDRED TEN BANKS AND CREDIT
UNIONS IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY
CURRENTLY PROVIDE SOME LEVEL OF
BANKING TO THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY. FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS THAT DO CHOOSE TO
PROVIDE BANKING SERVICES TO THE
INDUSTRY TAKE A CONSIDERABLE
RISK. NOT TO MENTION RIGOROUS
MONITORING AND REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS. MOST CANNABIS IS
BUSINESSES I SAID ARE SIMPLY
CASH BASED SYSTEMS AND PROVIDE.
A SERIOUS PUBLIC RISK THIS BILL
INCREASES THE ABILITY OF
LICENSED CANNABIS A COMPANIES
TO ACCESS FINANCIAL SERVICES
AYE ASPIRIN AYE VOTE. ANY
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM SEEING AND HEARING NON
FEDERAL SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ONE TIME. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
BELL LARGEST BRADFORD CABALLERO
I CHIANG ALI DOT FIVE TORONTO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER I GONZALEZ
I GROWTH HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO. HI HER TADO HI JACKSON I
JONES LEYVA FIVE MCGUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ MITCHELL I MONEY. I
MORLOCK GIRL NIELSEN AYE PAN
AYE PORTANTINO. HI RALPH. FIVE
RUBIO. I SKINNER. I STERN HI
I'M BURKE AYE WHAT KASKI. NO
WIENER. I WILK. LET'S GO BACK
AND CALL THE ROLL ONE MORE TIME
I BELIEVE WE HAVE A FULL HOUSE.
WHAT ONE MOMENT ONE MOMENT
PLEASE.
M. SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES BELL.
I BORJAS BRADFORD. CHIANG DALLY
GROWTH JONES MELENDEZ MORLOCK
MORALE WILK NOTED THAT
PROPONENTS OF. GONZALEZ NOW I
DON'T KNOW I DON'T KNOW. HIS
TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS. TO ALL WHAT
ARE WE MOVING A CALL ON THIS.
ALL RIGHT MOVING CALL I'M SORRY
SENATOR HERTZBERG MOVES TO CALL.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO FILE ITEM
ONE OLD ONE SENATOR WIENER.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TANG
AND ACTUALLY IN THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THERE OF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY SENATOR NGUYEN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
THREE. ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PHIL TING- THIS
BILL EXPANDS AN EXISTING
HOMELESSNESS PILOT PROGRAM
STATEWIDE. AND EXTENDS A SUNSET
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY SIX. IN
200-017-8930 TO ESTABLISH A
PILOT PROGRAM. TO GIVE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS GREATER REGULATORY
FLEXIBILITY TO EXPEDITE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF HOMELESS
SHELTERS. SINCE THE BILL'S
PASSAGE OAKLAND BERKELEY SAN
JOSE AND SAN FRANCISCO HAVE ALL
USED EIGHTY NINE THIRTY TWO. TO
GET DESPERATELY NEEDED HOMELESS
SHELTERS UP AND RUNNING. THE
PILOT PROGRAM WAS EXPANDED TO
ADDITIONAL CITIES AND COUNTIES
LAST YEAR. HOWEVER MORE AND
MORE CITIES ARE REQUESTING THIS
NEEDED FLEXIBILITY UNDER THIS.
BILL ALL CITIES AND COUNTIES
WILL BE ABLE TO ADOPT A
REASONABLE LOCAL STANDARDS FOR
HABITABILITY ZONING AND
CONSTRUCTION APPROVAL TO
STREAMLINE. BUILDING TEMPORARY
SHELTERS- THIS BILL ENJOYS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. S. RIVAL.
I'M SORRY. THIS IS BILL. TWENTY
FIVE FIFTY THREE. BY SEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. TANG N. BERMAN.
THAT IS A PRESENTATION. ALL
RIGHT VERY GOOD FOR ANY DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM SEEING
AND HEARING NONE BATUM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ONE TIME. ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES BELL I FOR
JUST BRADFORD. CABALLERO I
CHIANG DALLY DODD. I DURAZO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER. GONZALEZ I
GROWTH HERTZBERG AYE HILL HI
HUESO I HER TADO HI JACKSON ALL
RIGHT I JONES LEYVA. HI WIRE I
MELENDEZ MITCHELL I MONEY HI
MORLOCK GIRL NIELSEN. I PAN
FIVE PORTANTINO. I ROTH FIVE
RUBIO. I SKINNER. I STERN I AM
BURKE I Y. CASKEY I WIENER. I
WILK SENATOR WIENER MOVES TO A
CALL MOVING ON NOW TO FILE ONE
OH THREE SENATOR MCGUIRE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ FILE ONE
OH THREE. ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
ONE SIXTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
ACTUALLY NEED TO FIRE
PREVENTION SENATOR MCGUIRE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SB THIRTY ONE
SIXTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY WOMAN
FRIEDMAN DIRECTS CALIFORNICUM
FOOTAGE WITH THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER. IN AN ADVISORY
WORKING GROUP TO DEVELOP A
PARCEL OF A WILDFIRE RISK MODEL
TO HELP COMMUNITIES UNDERSTAND
THE RISK AND WHAT THE- WHAT
THEY CAN DO TO BE A REDUCE THAT
RISK THAT SO MANY NOW FACE IN
THIS ERA OF MAKE OUT WHILE AND
FIRES. A DEVELOPING A STANDARD
RISK MODEL WOULD ALLOW THE
STATE TO FAIRLY EVALUATE
EVALUATE THE MONEY SPENT IN THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE POLICIES
AND PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT ALL
COMMUNITIES BIG AND SMALL FOR
RISK REDUCTION WORK IS BEING
DONE THIS BILL IS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WOULD ASK
FOR AN ITEM. DEBATER DISK. ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING AND HEARING
ON MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ONE TIME. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES
BELL FIVE BURGESS BRADFORD
CABALLERO I CHIANG DALLY DOT I
TORONTO. HI GALGIANI I GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I GOWTH HERTZBERG.
HELLO HI HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
I'D HUESO HI PATADA. I JACKSON
ALL RIGHT I JONES LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S MITCHELL.
HI MY NAME FIVE MORLOCK EURO
NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH I RUBIO. HI SKINNER I
STERN I AM BURKE HI MY COUNTY I
WIENER AYE WILK. SENATOR
MCGUIRE MOVES TO CALL MOVING ON
NOW TO FILE ITEM WONDERFUL
EIGHT FILE ITEM ONE OH EIGHT.
SENATOR CAFIERO MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN FIFTY ONE BY SAM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA AN ACT
RELATING TO PROPERTY
ASSESSMENTS. CENTER CABALLERO
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE TO PRESENT AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY ONE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARAMBULA THIS BILL MAKES
THREE CHANGES TO THE PROPERTY
ASSESSED CLEAN ENERGY OR PACE
PROGRAM. FIRST IT REMOVES THE
PENALTY FOR PREPAYMENT WHICH IS
ALREADY A STANDARD INDUSTRY
PRACTICE SECOND IT PROHIBITS
PACE ADMINISTRATORS FROM
CONTRACTING WITH OWNERS WHO
HAVE REVERSE MORTGAGES AND
LASTLY IT REQUIRES PACE
ADMINISTRATORS TO DELIVER A
PRINTED COPY OF THE DISCLOSURE
TO THE PROPERTY OWNER UNLESS
THE OWNER OPT IN FOR ELECTRONIC
DELIVERY. THIS PROVIDES
CONSUMERS MORE TRANSPARENCY
ABOUT THE CONDITION OF THEIR
PACE CONTRACT THERE IS A
DIGITAL DIVIDE IN OUR STATE
OLDER AND LOW INCOME RESIDENTS
SOME OF WHOM MAY BE NON ENGLISH
SPEAKERS HAVE TROUBLE ACCESSING
ELECTRONIC DISCLOSURES A
WRITTEN DISCLOSURE PROVIDED
BEFORE ANY WORK ON THE OWNER'S
PROPERTY BEGINS PROVIDE
SAFEGUARDS FOR CONSUMERS BY
INCREASING TRANSPARENCY. AND
ACCESS TO INFORMATION THIS BILL
ENJOYS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
RECENT REMEMBER AMENDMENTS
REMOVE ALL OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ONE TIME. ALLEN FIVE ARCHULETA
I ATKINS I BATES BELL HI PORGES
BRADFORD CABALLERO I CHIANG
DALLY DODD. I TORONTO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER GONZALEZ I
GROWTH HERTZBERG. HILL AYE
HUESO I HER TADO HI JACKSON I
JONES LEYVA FIVE MCGUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ MITCHELL. I MONNING
FIVE MORLOCK GIRL NIELSEN. I
PAN FIVE PORTANTINO. I ROTH I
RUBIO. I SKINNER I STERN HI I'M
BURKE I WHITE HOUSE SKI FIVE
WIENER. FIVE WILK. CENTER
CABALLERO MOVES TO CALL MOVING
ON NOW TO FILE ITEM WONDERFUL
NINE SENATOR WHITE HOUSE
GETTING. FILE ITEM ONE OWN NINE.
THIRTY TO PROCEED ON THAT MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER OBERNOLTE AND
ACTUALLY TO COLLATERAL RECOVERY
SENATOR Y. CASKEY THIS SIMPLE
BILL SIMPLY EXTENDS THE TIME TO
AN EXPIRED REPOSSESSION AGENCY
LICENSE MAY BE RENEWED AND I
ASK FOR AN IPHONE IT ALLOWS A
FAMILY MEMBER. OF A QUALIFIED
MANAGER WHO IS TIED TO
REINSTATE THE LICENSE. DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM. I
THINK THIS GETS THE RECORD FOR
THE SHORTEST PRESENTATION OF
THE DAY ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ONE TIME ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES BELL I BORDERS BRADFORD
CABALLERO I CHIANG DALLY DODD.
HI TORONTO I GALGIANI I GLAZER
GONZALEZ I GROWTH HERTZBERG.
HELLO AYE HUESO. I HER TADO. HI
JACKSON BY I JONES LEYVA FIVE
MCGUIRE FIVE MELINDA'S MITCHELL.
I MONEY FIVE MORLOCK MORALE
NIELSEN. I PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH I RUBIO. I SKINNER I
STERN HI I'M BURKE I Y. CASKEY.
FIVE WIENER AYE WILK. BRADFORD
I'D- SENATOR MOVES AT A CALL
CENTER WORKERS CAN LOSE A CALL.
MOVING ON NOW WE HAVE TWO ITEMS
LEFT. ON OUR ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING IF OUR COLLEAGUES WHO
ARE IN THEIR OFFICES WOULD COME
DOWN TO THE FLOOR SO WE CAN
LIVE CALLS AND VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDARS. I'M SORRY.
ONE MOMENT. SO IF WE COULD GET
EVERYONE DOWN HERE SO WE CAN
LIFT THE CALLS. WE'RE GOING TO
GO ON NOW TO FILE ITEM ONE
ELEVEN. FILE ITEM ONE ELEVEN
SENATOR BILL. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON AND
ACTUALLY IN TO IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES. VENTURA
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW THE IN
HOME SUPPORT SERVICES ANNUAL
REASSESSMENTS TO BE PERFORMED
REMOTELY THROUGH TELEHEALTH AS
LONG AS THE CLIENTS MEET
CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS SEARCH AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
BILL ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON THIS ITEM. ONE MOMENT. WE
HAVE A FULL HOUSE WILL GO
THROUGH THE ROLE TWICE. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ONE SECOND
PLEASE. THIS IS. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN FIVE ARCHULETA. I ATKINS
AYE BATES BELL FIVE FOR JUST
BRADFORD I HAVE A ADAM I CHIANG.
DALLY DODD. I TORONTO I
GALGIANI I GLAZER. GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI HILL AYE
HUESO. I HER TADO. HI JACKSON
ALL RIGHT I JONES LEYVA HI WIRE.
I MELENDEZ MITCHELL. I MONEY I
MORLOCK MORALE NIELSEN. PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH I RUBIO. I
SKINNER. I STERN I AM BURKE AYE
AYE CASKEY AYE WIENER AYE WILK.
RESTRICTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ONE MORE TIME. BATES PURCHASE
CHIANG DALLY. GLAZER. I GROWTH
JONES MELENDEZ MORLOCK MORALE
NIELSEN. WILK VICE TWENTY NINE
OH ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES OUR
FINAL ITEM ON THE ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING FILE TODAY IS AB
ONE TWELVE. AND THAT IS BEING
FLOOR MANAGED BY. SENATOR ROTH
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN TEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD AND
ACTUALLY IN THE PHARMACY
SENATOR ROTH THANK ABOUT A
PRESIDENT WITH A COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC IN THE GOAL
OF NOT JUST RAPID DEPLOYMENT
BUT ALSO DEPLOYMENT OF THE
VACCINE. IT WILL BE VALUABLE TO
HAVE PHARMACISTS TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THIS VACCINE SHOULD BE
READY BY THE END OF THE YEAR OR
EARLY NEXT YEAR THIS BILL DOES
EXACTLY THAT FOR THAT REASON I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH
ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING AND HEARING
NON MADAM SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS FIVE BATES BELL FIVE
FORGES RADFORD I HAVE A I
CHIANG DALLY DODD. FIVE TO RAZA.
I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH HERTZBERG I
HILL AYE HUESO. I HER TADO HI
JACKSON I JONES LEYVA. I
REQUIRE I MELENDEZ MITCHELL. I
MONEY I MORLOCK MORALE NIELSEN
AYE PAN FIVE PORTANTINO. I ROTH
I RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN AYE
NUMBER I WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WIENER AYE WILK. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE
TIME PLEASE. BATES OKAY FOR
JUST. CHIANG DALLY GROWTH JONES
MELENDEZ WARLOCK MORALE WILK.
ALL EYES THIRTY KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO
NOW LIFT THE CALLS ON THE
NUMBER OF ITEMS. BEEN A FUTURE
STUFF GIVE US A MOMENT.
RIGHT
COLLEAGUES WE'RE GONNA LIVE THE
CALL CENTER GO THROUGH THE ROLE
ONE TIME ON EACH OF THESE ITEMS.
STARTING WITH FILE ITEM FOR
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES PORGES
CHIANG DALLY GLAZER I GROWTH
JONES MELENDEZ MORLOCK MORALE
NIELSEN. SKINNER I WILK. IS
TWENTY NINE NO NO ZERO THAT
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED FILE
ITEM SIX PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BATES FOR JEFF CHANG.
DALLY GLAZER I GROWTH JONES
MELENDEZ MORLOCK MORALE NIELSEN.
WILK HIS TWENTY NINE NOSHIRO
THAT APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED
FILE ITEM SEVEN PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES OR JUST
HANG ALLEY GLAZER I GROWTH
JONES MELENDEZ MORLOCK MORALE
NIELSEN. WILK I TWENTY NINE OH
ZERO THAT APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED FILE ITEM EIGHT
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BASICS FOR JUST CHIANG DALLY
GROVE HERTZBERG I JONES MCGUIRE
AYE MELINDA'S MORLOCK MORALE
NIELSEN. WILK I TWENTY NINE NO
ZERO THE OINTMENT IS CONFIRMED
FILE ITEM TEN PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS I BATES
GORGEOUS CHIANG DALLY GROVE
HERTZBERG. I JONES MCGUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ MORLOCK MORALE NIELSEN
WILK ICE TWENTY NINE OH ZERO
THE APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED
THE LAST OF THE APPOINTMENTS
FILE ITEM ELEVEN PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. FAITH FOR
JUST CHIANG DALLY GROVE. JONES
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ MORLOCK
MORALE NIELSEN WILK HIS TWENTY
NINE OH ZERO THAT APPOINTMENT
IS CONFIRMED GOING BACK NOW TO
SENATE THIRD READING. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON FILE
ITEM. THIRTEEN BATES BELL I FOR
JUST CHIANG DALLY GLAZER I
GROWTH JONES MELENDEZ MORLOCK
MOREAU NIELSEN. WILK HIS TWENTY
NINE OH ZERO ASSEMBLY MEMON
ARKAN IN AGAIN THE NEXT THREE
ITEMS ARE ALSO ON THE
UNFINISHED BUSINESS CALENDAR
FILE ITEM NINETEEN PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES BELL
I FOR JUST CHIANG DALLY GLAZER
I GROWTH JONES MELENDEZ MORLOCK
MORALE WILK HIGHS THIRTY KNOWS
ZERO ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS OR CAN
CURTAIN FILE ITEM TWENTY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. FAITH
BELL I FORGES CHIANG DALLY
GLAZER I GROWTH JONES MCGUIRE
AYE MELINDA'S MORLOCK MORALE
NIELSEN. SKINNER I WILK VICE
TWENTY NINE NO ZERO ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CAN CURTAIN
MOVING ALONG NOW TO ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING CALENDAR. FILE
ITEM TWENTY SIX PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE TIME. FAITH
WELL I FOR JUST CHIANG DALLY
GLAZER. AYE DROVE JONES
MELENDEZ MORLOCK MORALE SKINNER.
I WILK VICE THIRTY KNOWS ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE TIME. BATES
BELL I FOR JUST CHIANG DALLY
GLAZER AYE GROVE JONES MELENDEZ
WARLOCK MORALE SKINNER. I WILK
IS THIRTY KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE
URGENCY PRICE THIRTY NO ZERO ON
THE MEASURE THE MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM THIRTY ONE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ONE
TIME PLEASE BATES BELL. I FOR
JUST CHIANG DALLY GLAZER. I
DROVE JONES MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S
MORLOCK MORALE SKINNER I WILK.
MARCH THIRTY NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM THIRTY
TWO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ATKINS. YEAH ATKINS I
BATES BELL I FOR JUST CHIANG
DALLY GLAZER I GROWTH JONES
MELENDEZ MORLOCK MORALE NIELSEN.
I SKINNER. I WILK MARCH THIRTY
NOSHIRO THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM THIRTY
NINE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE TIME. BATES BELL I
BORJAS CHANG DALLY GLAZER I
GROWTH JONES MELENDEZ MORLOCK
MORALE SKINNER. I WILK VICE
THIRTY KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM FORTY. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES
BELL I FOR JUST CHIANG DALLY
GLAZER I GROWTH JONES MELENDEZ
MONNING. I MORLOCK MORALE
SKINNER. ROTH NO DOUBT I.
SKINNER WILK. HIS TWENTY NINE
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSAGE
FILE ITEM FORTY THREE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE
TIME. YOUR. BATES BELL I FOR
JUST CHIANG DALLY DORADO. I AS
I GROWTH JONES MELENDEZ MORLOCK
MORALE NIELSEN FIVE SKINNER I
WILK VICE THIRTEEN OH ZERO IN
THE URGENCY ICE THIRTY NO ZERO
ON THE MEASURE THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM FORTY FIVE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE TIME. BATES BELL I FOR JUST
CHIANG DALLY GLAZER I GROWTH
JONES MELENDEZ MORLOCK MORALE
NIELSEN AYE SKINNER AYE WILK
RICE THIRTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM FORTY SIX
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BATES BELL I FOR JUST CHIANG
DALLY GLAZER. I GROWTH JONES
MELENDEZ MORLOCK MORALE NIELSEN.
I SKINNER AYE WILK MARCH THIRTY
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM FIFTY ONE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE TIME. BATES
BELL I FOR JUST CHIANG DALLY
GLAZER I GROWTH JONES MELENDEZ
MORLOCK MORALE SKINNER I WILK.
HIGHS THIRTY NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM SIXTY
FILE ITEM SIXTY ADAM SCHECHTER
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE TIME. BATES BELL I FOR JUST
CHIANG DALLY GLAZER I GROWTH
JONES MELENDEZ MORLOCK MORALE
SKINNER. I WILK. ALMOST THIRTY
NOSHIRO THE MEASURE FILE ITEM
SIXTY ONE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE TIME. I
LARGEST BRADFORD I CHIANG DALLY
GLAZER I GROWTH JONES MELENDEZ
MORLOCK MORALE SKINNER. I WILK
HIGHS THIRTY NO ZERO IN THE
URGENCY HIGHS THIRTY KNOWS
YOU'RE ON THE MEASURE THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM SIXTY
FIVE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE TIME. BATES BELL I
FOR JUST BRADFORD. I CHIANG
DALLY GLAZER. I GROWTH
HERTZBERG. I JONES MELENDEZ
MORE LOCK NO RAIL SKINNER. I
WILK ICE THIRTY NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM SIXTY
SIX PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE TIME IN HIS LIFE.
BATES BELL I FOR. BRADFORD I
CHIANG DALLY DURAZO. I GLAZER I
GROWTH. JONES MELENDEZ MORLOCK
MORALE WILK I H. THIRTY NOS
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
IT WE
JUST ENJOYED IS SEND MOMENT
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK. TO FILE
ITEM SEVENTY FIVE FILE ITEM
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE TIME. BATES
WELL I FOR JUST. BRADFORD I
COME BY HANG. DALLY GLAZER I
GROWTH. JONES MELENDEZ. MORLOCK
MORALE WILK HIGHS THIRTY KNOWS
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES ITEM
SEVENTY SEVEN. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE TIME. BATES
BELL FIVE FOR JUST. BRADFORD I
CHIANG. DALLY GLAZER I GROWTH.
JONES MELENDEZ MORLOCK. MORALE
WILK VICE THIRTY NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE TIME. BATES
WELL. I FOR JUST BRADFORD I
CHIANG DALLY DORADO. I GLAZER I
GROWTH. JONES MELENDEZ MORLOCK
AROUND NIELSEN I WILK HIGHS
THIRTY NO ZERO IN THE URGENCY
ICE THIRTY KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE
MEASURE THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM. EIGHTY
SIX PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE TIME. BATES WELL I
FOR JUST. BRADFORD I CHIANG.
DALLY DORADO I GROWTH. JONES
MELENDEZ MORLOCK MORALE WILK.
HIGHS THIRTY NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY ICE THIRTY KNOWS YOU'RE
ON THE MEASURE THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM NINETY SIX
MADAMSECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE TIME. BATES
BELL HI PORGES. BRADFORD I
CHIANG DALLY GROVE JONES.
MELENDEZ MORLOCK MORALE WILK.
HIGHS THIRTY NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM NINETY
SEVEN PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BATES BELL. I FOR JUST
BRADFORD I CHIANG. DALLY GROWTH.
JONES MELENDEZ. MORLOCK MORRELL.
NIELSEN. I WILK HIGHS THIRTY
KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE URGENCY ICE
THIRTEEN OH ZERO ON THE MEASURE
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE HUNDRED FILE ITEM
ONE HUNDRED PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS A ONE TIME.
BATES FOR JUST. BRADFORD HI
CHIANG. DALLY GROVE. JONES
MELENDEZ MORLOCK HELLO WILK I
SHOULD THE TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS
TO THE MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
ONE OR ONE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE TIME. ON THE
APEX. FOR JEFF. BRADFORD I
CHIANG. DALLY GLAZER I GROWTH.
JONES MELENDEZ MORLOCK. ZERO
WILK HIS THIRTEEN OH ZERO ON
THE URGENCY HIS THIRTY KNOWS
YOU'RE ON THE MEASURE THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM. ONE
OH THREE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE TIME. BATESFOR
JUST. BRADFORD I CHIANG DALLY
GLAZER I GROVE JONES MELENDEZ
MORLOCK MORALE WILK VICE THIRTY
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE OH EIGHT PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE TIME.
BATES BORJAS BRADFORD I CHIANG.
DALLY. GLAZER I GROWTH
HERTZBERG I JONES. MELENDEZ
MORLOCK MORALE WILK. HIGHS
THIRTY NOSHIRO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM ONE OR NINE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BATES FOR JUST CHIANG. DALLY
GLAZER I GROWTH. HERTZBERG I
JONES MELENDEZ MORLOCK MORALE
WILK. VICE THIRTY NOSHIRO THE
MEASURE PASSES IN OUR FINAL
ITEM. THAT'S IT THAT'S ALL THAT
FILE ITEM. NO THAT'S IT. THAT
IS IT IF YOU WOULD HOLD ONE
SECOND PLEASE. IT'S TAKEN TIME
OUT FOR A TO GET BACK INTO THAT
JAN MODE. FOR EITHER. THE HAHA.
YES THAT. IS THAT WHAT.
YEAH.
YEAH. HE WANTED. TO SENATOR
MITCHELL FOR PURPOSE
ANNOUNCEMENTS I'M NOT A
PRESIDENT WITHOUT OBJECTION TO
INFORM THE MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW%
COMMITTEE THERE. WILL BE NO
BUDGET COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY.
RIGHT FURTHER. BUDGET CUTS
MEETINGS TO DAY OR HEARINGS.
ANY OTHER ANNOUNCEMENTS. THAT'S.
MY COLLEAGUES IF WE COULD TO
COME BACK TOGETHER HERE UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS SENATOR
MIKE. SENATOR HERTZBERG THE
FLOOR IS YOURS ONE SECOND.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS
THERE'S A RESOLUTION OF THE
DESK REQUESTING PERMISSION TO
SPEND JOINT RULE SIXTY ONE AND
SIXTY TWO. FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ALLOWING POLICY IN FISCAL
COMMITTEES TO MEET AND HEAR
MEASURES AND AMEND MEASURES ON
THE FLOOR AS DIRECTED BY THE
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE ON
RULES. PAST RIVAL. THANK YOU
SENATOR NELSON NOT A PRESENT I
WOULD REQUEST THAT WE- WOULD DO
A PREVIOUS ROLL CALL WITH ME
ABSTAINING BUT THAT WOULD NOT
HOLD ANYTHING UP IF WE DO IT
THAT WAY ALTHOUGH IT ON ALL OF
THESE BILLS UNFORTUNATELY WE
DON'T HAVE A NANIMOUS OR A
PRIOR ROLL CALL WE CAN USE MY
APOLOGY SO WE WILL HAVE TO.
VOTE ON THE MATTER AND IT IS
NOT DEBATABLE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. RESULT OF THAT
JOINT RULES OF SIXTY ONE AND
SIXTY TO BE DISPENSED WITH AS
REQUESTED. RIGHT SENATOR
HERTZBERG IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. CENTER NIELSEN. IS I
GUESS ASKING FOR NO VOTE WITH
THAT MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES.
WELL I BOARD JUST. BRADFORD I
HAVE ITEM I CHIANG. DALLY DODD
I DURAZO HI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
I GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG
I HILL AYE HUESO. I HER TADO HI
JACKSON I JONES. LEYVA. FIVE
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ. MITCHELL
I MONNING AYE MORLOCK MORALE
NIELSEN. PAM FIVE PORTANTINO HI
RALPH I RUBIO. I SKINNER I
STERN. HI NUMBER ALL RIGHT I
WHITE HOUSE SKI. I WIENE HI
WILK. HIS TWENTY NINE NO ZERO
THE MOTION CARRIES THE DRAWING
RULES ARE SUSPENDED SENATOR
HERTZBERG FOR PURPOSE THANK YOU
UNDER A MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
MADAM PRESIDENT. MEMBERS I MOVE
THE SENATE RULES BE SUSPENDED
THE PURPOSE OF AMENDING
MEASURES IN COMMITTEE AS
DIRECTED BY THE CHAIR. OF THE
CANADIAN RULES. S. OR DROP THE
PREVIOUS VOTE. THANK YOU SIR
HERTZBERG CENTER NIELSEN WOULD
YOU LIKE TO USE THE PREVIOUS
ROLL CALL ON THIS IT WILL BE-
SO ORDERED ICE TWENTY. TWENTY
NINE NO ZERO RESOLUTION THE
MOTION CARRIES. THE JOINT RULES
ARE SUSPENDED SENATE RULES
EXCUSE ME THAT WAS FOR SENATE
RULES THE SENATE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED. ALL RIGHT ANY OTHER.
ANNOUNCEMENTS SEIGNER MADAM PRO
TEM THE DESK IS CLEAR. CALLER
THANK YOU WELL THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT WE MANAGE TO PASS
TWENTY SEVEN AB'S TODAY THREE
SENATE BILLS AND SIX
APPOINTMENTS WE HAVE ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY TWO REMAINING
ASSEMBLY BILLS WITH ABOUT
NINETY NINE OF THOSE BE IN ON
CONSENT JUST TO GIVE YOU. AN
OVERVIEW SO- THANK YOU TODAY
FOR YOUR WORK. AND OUR NEXT
FLOOR SESSION IS TO FRIDAY
AUGUST WHEN EIGHTH TWENTY
TWENTY AT NINE AM THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. THANK YOU
MADAM PRO TEM. OR IF THERE IS
NO OTHER BUSINESS. THE DESK IS
CLEAR AND THE SENATE WILL BE
ADJOURNED WE CONVENE ON FRIDAY
AT NINE AM. YEAH.